THAT'S RIGHT
GOOD MORNING THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION WILL COME TO ORDER
AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE THE
ONGOING COVERT NINETEEN REST THE
SENATE CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE
PUBLIC IT IS PROVIDED ACCESS TO
BOTH IN PERSON A TELECONFERENCE
BURKE DISSIPATION FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT
VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS THE
PURCHASE OF THE TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT ALL MELTED
NOW TODAY'S PARTICIPANT NUMBERS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE
ONE ONE FOUR OO FOR TODAY'S
INFORMATIONAL HEARING WILL
BE TAKING HEARING FROM OUR
PANELISTS LISTED ON THE AGENDA
PRIOR TO TAKING ANY PUBLIC
COMMENT WHAT'S WE HEAR FROM
OUR PANELISTS WE WILL HAVE
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO COMMENT ON
THE TOPICS ON TODAY'S AGENDA
FOR BILL HEARING THE COMMITTEE
WILL OUT TO ME WITNESSES PER
SIDE LIMIT EACH WITNESS TWO
MINUTES EACH AND WE WILL KEEP
TRACK OF THE TIME TO MAKE
SURE YOUR BRIEF ALWAYS WISHING
TO TESTIFY MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS THEIR NAME AFFILIATION
POSITION ON THE MEASURES WE
WILL LIMIT BOTH THE SUPPORTERS
AND THE OPPOSITION TO TEN
MINUTES PER SIDE I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN IN THE INDIVIDUAL
WHO IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS
REMOVED WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARING HERE ON THE
IN THE -- STREET BUILDING AND
I ASK ALL MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
TO BE PUT PRESENT IN ROOM TWELVE
HUNDRED SO WE CAN ESTABLISH
OUR QUORUM SO WE CAN MOVE THIS
MEETING FORD WE WILL BEGIN
WITH OUR INFORMATIONAL HEARING
HEARING FOLLOWED BY OUR BILL
HEARING SO TODAY WERE
HOLDING ANY INFORMATION HEARING
ON THE NEW COMPACTS BETWEEN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA AS WELL
AS THE CONTACT BETWEEN THE STATE
IN SANTA ROSA INDIAN COMMUNITY
FOR THOSE OF YOU UNFAMILIAR
WITH THE SENATE'S PROCEDURE
THE ESTABLISH POLICIES ALLOWS
FOR AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING
ON THE DETAILS OF THE COMPACT
TO BE FOLLOWED BY A VOTE ON THE
SENATE FLOOR NO VOTE WILL BE
TAKING HERE TAKING UP HERE TODAY
THE VEHICLE FOR RATIFICATION FOR
THESE COMPACT EXTENSIONS WILL
BE SB NINE HUNDRED BY SENATOR
FURTADO I BELIEVE MR --
VOCALLY -- SENIOR ADVISER FOR
GOVERNOR NEWSOM IS HERE --
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BE GET
THANK YOU CHAIRMAN DIED
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SCREWED
ADD MY NAME IS NATE VOGEL AND
THE SENIOR ADVISER FOR TRAVEL
NEGOTIATIONS ARE THE GOVERNOR
A COMPACT I'M ABOUT TO GO
OVER TODAY ARE THE SECOND
ITERATION OF TRIBAL STATE GAMING
COMPACT PREVIOUSLY APPROVED
BY THE LEGISLATURE AND IT'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE SESSION THIS
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS REALLY
A TESTAMENT TO THE HARD WORK
AND A GOOD AMOUNT OF PATIENCE
FROM SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA AND
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA I'D LIKE
TO THANK SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
CHAIR LEO CISCO WHO'S HERE TODAY
AND MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA CHAIR
JOSE SIMON FOR THEIR EFFORTS TO
GET US TO THIS HEARING LET ME
BEGIN WITH A SHORT BACKGROUND
TO THESE COMPACTS IN APRIL
TWENTY TWENTY ONE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA AND SANTA ROSA
RANCHERIA SIGN NEW TRIBAL STATE
GAMING COMPACTS WITH THE STATE
THOSE CONTACTS WERE INTENDED
TO REPLACE THEIR EXISTING
COMPACTS WHICH WERE SIGNED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE AND ARE
SET TO EXPIRE IN JUNE OF THIS
YEAR IN AUGUST TWENTY TWENTY
ONE THE LEGISLATURE APPROVED
THE TRIBES COMPACTS WHICH WERE
THEN WENT TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR FOR REQUIRED FORTY
FIVE DAY REVIEW UNDER A GRAPH
IN NOVEMBER TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR
DISAPPROVE THE TRIBE'S CONTACTS
IN ISSUED A LETTER EXPLAINING
THAT IN THE DEPARTMENT'S
VIEW THE COMPACTS CONTAIN
TERMS OUTSIDE THE SCOPE OF A
GRAND SINCE THE TIME OF THOSE
DISAPPROVAL SO THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE CONDUCTED A COMPREHENSIVE
REVIEW OF PRIOR APPROVED
COMPACTS DEEMED APPROVED LETTERS
FOR CONTACTS THAT TOOK EFFECT
BY OPERATION OF LAW PROCEDURES
ISSUE DIRECTLY BY INTERIOR CASE
LAW FROM THE NINTH CIRCUIT AND
COMPAQ'S APPROVED BY INTERIOR
AND OTHER STATES SUCH AS ARIZONA
AT THE SAME TIME THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE WAS CONDUCTING ITS
REVIEW SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA
AND MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA WE'RE
WORKING WITH THE STATE AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR TO
HELP GUIDE FUTURE NEGOTIATIONS
INFORMED BY ALL OF THIS WORK
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE NEGOTIATED
WITH SANTA ROSA RANCHERIA AND
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA UPDATES
TO THOSE CONTACTS THAT WERE
SIGNED IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE
THE TWO CONTACTS IN FRONT
OF THE COMMITTEE TODAY ARE
THE RESULT IT'S ALL OF THAT
CLOSE COLLABORATION BETWEEN
THE STATE AND THE TRIBES
THE VAST MAJORITY OF THE TERMS
IN THESE TWO CONTACTS REMAIN
THE SAME AS IN THE TWENTY
TWENTY ONE COMPACTS WHICH I
PREVIOUSLY WENT OVER WITH THE
COMMITTEE IN AUGUST OF LAST
YEAR I'LL HIGHLIGHT THE KEY
UPDATES FOR THESE NEW CONTACTS
THE GAMING FACILITY DEFINITION
WAS REVISED TO MORE CLOSELY
TRACKED THE DEFINITION APPROVED
BY INTERIOR IN NINETEEN NINETY
NINE CONTACTS THE DEFINITION
WAS NARROWED CONSISTENT WITH
OTHER RECENT CONTACTS TO
FOCUS ON FACILITIES WITH THE
PRINCIPAL PURPOSE OF CENTER
SERVING THE GAMING OPERATION
THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW NOTICE
PROVISIONS CLARIFY WHO AND
WHEN THE TRIBES MUST NOTIFY
DURING THE ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW
PROCESS AND WHICH ENTITIES ARE
ENTITLED TO REQUEST A MEET AND
CONFER WITH THE TRIBES REGARDING
MITIGATION THE DEFINITE MISSION
OF A PROJECT THAT MUST UNDERGO
ENVIRONMENTAL REVIEW WAS
REVISED TO CLARIFY THAT ONLY
DEVELOPMENT TYPE ACTIVITIES
TRIGGER THAT REVIEW THIS IS
CONSISTENT WITH THE STATE'S
LONGSTANDING APPROACH TO COMPACT
IMPLEMENTATION THE DEPARTMENT
OF INTERIOR ALSO EXPRESSED
CONCERNS THAT THE COMPACT
BROADLY REGULATED TOBACCO SALES
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE STATE AND THE TRIBES FOR
THE TWENTY TWENTY ONE COMPAQ'S
THESE UPDATED CONTACTS FOCUS
ON PROHIBITING TOBACCO SALES TO
MINORS AT THE GAMING FACILITY
IN ACCORDANCE WITH FEDERAL LAW
FEDERAL LAW AND STATE LAW NOW
HAVE THE SAME MINIMUM AGE FOR
PURCHASE THEIR TO BE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OLD ADDITIONALLY THE
TRIBES HAVE AGREED TO CONTINUE
THEIR PRACTICE OF RECOGNIZING
STATE SPOUSAL AND CHILD SUPPORT
ORDERS AGAINST NON TRIBAL MEMBER
CASINO EMPLOYEES BUT AN UPDATED
PROVISION ALSO HIGHLIGHTS
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS AS A
LICENSING REQUIREMENT TO ENSURE
APPLICANTS ARE IN COMPLIANCE
WITH LEGAL OBLIGATIONS
FINALLY BOTH TRIED DEGREE
TO REVISE LANGUAGE REGARDING
COMPLIANCE WITH THE TRIBAL
LABOR RELATIONS ORDINANCE
TO CLARIFY THE INTENT OF
THE STATE AND THE TRIBES
THAT BY AGREEING TO MAINTAIN
THE TRIBAL LABOR RELATIONS
ORDINANCE THE TRIBES ARE ALSO
AGREEING TO COMPLY WITH IT
I'D LIKE TO END BY SAYING THAT
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE BELIEVES
THESE CHANGES APPROPRIATELY
ADDRESS THE CONCERNS OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR AND
SUPPORTS A RATIFICATION BY THE
LEGISLATURE I'LL BE AVAILABLE
FOR ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS
THANK YOU THANK YOU THIS VOCALLY
SORRY FOR -- BOTCHING YOUR
NAME YEP ONCE AGAIN I APOLOGIZE
I BEFORE WE MOVED TO QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS BY MEMBERS I WANT
TO INVITE THE PUBLIC -- JUST
TO GET THEM PREPARED -- TO
BE ABLE TO DIAL IN SO WE'RE
READY AND AND ROLLING WHEN
WE GET TO THEM THAT NUMBER IS
EIGHT FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE
SIX THREE SIX FOUR -- WITH THE
ACCESS CODE ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR -- WILL NOW BRING
THE DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
NOT SEEING ANY -- MISERABLY
I'LL COVER YOU THAT THE CHANGES
MADE TO THESE CONTACTS WILL
BE SUFFICIENT TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE NOT REJECTED -- BY
DEPARTMENT OF INTERIOR YEAH I
HAVEN'T THERE'S NO GUARANTEE
UNTIL IT ACTUALLY GOES THROUGH
THE REVIEW THE DEPARTMENT CAN'T
GET ANY SORT OF GUARANTEES
UNTIL THEY ACTUALLY DO THEIR
FORTY FIVE DAY REVIEW BUT I'M
CONFIDENT THAT THAT CONCERNS
THAT THEY EXPRESSED IN THEIR
LETTER ARE DRESSED IN THESE NEW
CONTACTS WILL BE ABLE TO TAKE
EFFECT UNDER A GREAT VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE'LL NOW
MOVE ON -- TO ANYONE
WANTING TO PROVIDE -- PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IS THERE ANYBODY HERE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD
AND TESTIFY PLEASE COME FORWARD
MARCH TWENTY GERMAN DODD MEMBERS
ASCENT MY NAME IS LEO CISCO
-- -- CENTER WAS RANCHERIA
TRIBAL CHAIRMAN REPRESENTING THE
TOUCHY OKAY PEOPLE AND -- WHEN I
THINK THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE FOR
FOR THE HARD WORK AND DEDICATION
THAT THEY PROVIDED WITH US TO
WORK IN THE GOOD FAITH WITH
THE TRIBE ALSO WITH THE MISSING
DATA BERKELEY AND ALSO WE BEGIN
WITH AN UNNAMED MARC AND -- THIS
CONTACT IS GONNA SOLIDIFY --
OUR PEOPLE FOR THE NEXT TWENTY
FIVE YEARS AND WE WANT TO THANK
A GERMAN OFF WORKING WITH THE
TRIBE AS WELL AND AGAIN SENT
MEMBERS SENATE YOU HAVE A GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
CHAIRMAN NEXT MORNING
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND THE
COMMITTEE HI MY NAME'S MICHELLE
APPENA I'M AN ATTORNEY FOR
MIDDLETOWN RANCHERIA IN SANTA
ROSA RANCHERIA TOUCHY TRIBE I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE MIDDLETOWN
RANCHERIA -- TO EXPRESS OUR
GRATITUDE TO THE STATE TO
NATHAN AND THE COMMITTEES IN
THE LEGISLATURE FOR WORKING
WITH US TO GET THESE COMPACTS
RATIFIED AND APPROVED AND WE
ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU
SEE NOBODY ELSE COMING FORWARD
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
COMEDY THE TELECONFERENCE
ARVEST MODERATOR GOOD MORNING
-- PLEASE PROP THE INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO PROVIDE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY AND FEEL FREE TO
OPEN ALLIANCE NOW
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO PROVIDE OR OR OPPOSITION
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN
WE MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END
OF ONE MOMENT
FOR FIRST COME IN PLEASE
YEAH MUENCHEN YEAH
WILK IS STILL AROUND YEAH
WITH ONE HAND YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
MY INTENT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN ONE MOMENT PLEASE
-- NINE TEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WE CAN
THANK YOU MY NAME IS ALYSSA
SONORA I AM WITH LOS ANGELES
EDUCATORS AND PARENTS UNITED
EN LOS ANGELES CALIFORNIA
WORK ADVOCATING -- TO
HAVE YOU ALL UNDERSTAND AND
RECOGNIZE THAT HAVING A STATE
OF EMERGENCY OVER A SIGNIFICANT
TIME CAUSES MORE DAMAGE
TO PEOPLE BUSINESS SAID
THAT I'M SORRY MA'AM YOU'RE
ON YOU'RE ON THE WRONG TOPIC
-- YEAH YOU'RE GONNA HAVE TO
CALL AND LOOK AT THE AGENDA AND
AND -- CALL IN LATER WHEN THAT
BILLS HEARD THANK YOU SO MUCH
I NEXT COMMENTER ON COMMENTER
ON THE -- COMPACT PLEASE
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THE FRONT --
OKAY -- I
WOULD LIKE TO --
THANK YOU EVERYBODY THAT
CAME HERE TODAY AND -- WE'RE
DONE WITH OUR INFORMATIONAL
HEARING AND WE'RE GONNA BE
MOVING ON TO OUR BILL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE CAN
I TAKE A QUICK RECESSED JUST
SO WE CAN -- TAKE CARE OF -- --
POTENTIAL AUTHOR ISSUE YOU
JUST -- PROBABLY TWO MINUTES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT --
I DON'T WE CANNOT ESTABLISH A
QUORUM AT THIS POINT TIME SO
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON AS A --
SUBCOMMITTEE --
WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. NINE
ET BY SENATOR WIENER I DO
WANT TO MAKE IT CLEAR THAT --
THERE'S A BILL COMING OUT FROM
CENTER WILL WHICH WILL BE NEXT
THE RESULT OF CENTER WILL NOT
BE HERE THAT'S -- ITEM NUMBER
TEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY
ONE SKEWS ME THE IS TWO
BILLS SB ELEVEN S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN --
THE SERVER BOARDS ARE STILL HERE
THOUGH DON'T WORRY ABOUT
IT -- CENTER WIENER GOOD MORNING
PLEASE PROCEED GREAT THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND -- COMMENCED
OUT FOR WORKING WITH US AND
HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS --
I TODAY PRESENTING SENATE
BILL NINE EIGHTY A BILL TO
MAKE IT EASIER FOR SMALL
BUSINESSES -- TO FILL VACANT
STOREFRONTS BY SIMPLIFYING --
SEVERAL ELEMENTS OF THE LIQUOR
LICENSE APPLICATION PROCESS AND
RETURNING SOME RESPONSIBILITY
TO LOCAL COMMUNITIES -- BEFORE
THE COVER NINETEEN PANDEMIC --
A VARIETY OF ALTI TO APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS HINDERED
RESTAURANTS AND BARS ABILITY
TO REALLY START NEW BUSINESSES
AND TO OPEN UP -- CALIFORNIA
SMALL BUSINESSES OFTEN FACE
SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES AND
NAVIGATING -- THE CONVOLUTED AND
VERY OVERLY LONG LIQUOR
LICENSE PROCESS AND BARRIERS
CAN MAKE IT DIFFICULT FOR
ENTREPRENEURS TO OPEN EXPAND
OR TAILOR THEIR OPERATIONS
-- TO SERVE THE COMMUNITY
UNDER CURRENT LAW -- UNDER
-- B. B. C. ACTS ON ABC
-- CAN DENY THE ISSUANCE OF
A RETAIL LICENSE FOR THE SOLE
REASON THAT THE LICENSE IS
LOCATED WITHIN A HUNDRED FEET
OF A RESIDENTS SB NINE EIGHTY
WILL AND THAT PRACTICE AND
WILL MAKE CLEAR THAT ABC TO NOT
DENY EXCLUSIVELY BASED ON IT
BEING WITHIN A HUNDRED FEET
-- WE KNOW THAT PARTICULARLY IN
MANY COMMUNITIES WHERE WE HAVE
A LOT OF DENSITY AND EVERYTHING
IS CLOSE TOGETHER -- IT CAN BE
ALL BUT IMPOSSIBLE TO FIND A
LOCATION THAT IS NOT WITHIN A
HUNDRED FEET -- OF A RESIDENCE
-- THAT THE LAW WILL STILL
ALLOW A. B. C. SIGNIFICANT
FLEXIBILITY -- IN TERMS TO
DETERMINING WHETHER A PARTICULAR
LICENSE WILL INTERFERE -- WITH
QUIET ENJOYMENT OF NEIGHBORS
THEY WON'T LOSE THAT ABILITY
-- BUT THEY WON'T BE ABLE TO
DENY EXCLUSIVELY BASED ON THE
HUNDREDS ARE BEING WITHIN A
HUNDRED FEET -- IN ADDITION
CURRENT STATE LAW REQUIRES
AN APPLICANT TO MAIL AND
NOTIFICATIONS EVERY RESIDENT
WITHIN A FIVE HUNDRED FOOT --
RADIUS OF THE PREMISES SB
NINE EIGHTY WILL BY DEFAULT
THAT -- IT'S ALREADY TOO CITIES
CITIES WILL BE ABLE TO DECIDE
WHAT KIND OF NOTIFICATION IS
REQUIRED THEY CAN STICK WITH
THE FIVE HUNDRED FEET OR THEY
CAN DO -- SOMETHING ELSE AGAIN
PARTICULARLY IN A DENSE URBAN
ENVIRONMENT -- IT'S FIVE HUNDRED
FEET CAN SWEEP AND THOUSANDS
OF HOMES PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT
IMPACTED IN ANY WAY -- BY
THE POTENTIAL BAR OR RESTAURANT
AND THE CURRENT FIVE HUNDRED
FOOT NOTIFICATION RULE CAN BE
EXTREMELY EXPENSIVE AND IT
IS ONE SIZE FITS ALL TREATS
A RURAL COMMUNITY THE SAME AS
A DENSE URBAN ENVIRONMENTS SO
THIS WILL SIMPLY ALLOW CITIES
TO DECIDE WHAT KIND OF NOTICE
OF ANY WEATHER TO TAILORED TO
PARTICULAR LOCATIONS -- AND
SO FORTH -- IN ADDITION
UNDER CURRENT LAW -- IT'S A
-- LICENSE APPLICANT WITHDRAWS
THE APPLICATION -- IN ORDER
TO BE RESPONSIVE TO A PROTEST
-- THE APPLICANT CANNOT
RESUBMIT THE APPLICATION FOR
A FULL YEAR EVEN IF THEY'RE
WITHDRAWING A IN ORDER WORK
WITH THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
RECONFIGURE AT AND THEN REFILE
IT THEY'RE AUTOMATICALLY
PENALIZING CAN'T RESUBMIT FOR
A YEAR -- THIS LEGISLATION WILL
ELIMINATE THAT PROHIBITION HI
IN ADDITION UNDER CURRENT LAW
IF YOU SUBMIT AN APPLICATION
AND THEN THERE'S A PROTEST
AND THEN YOU WITHDRAW THE
APPLICATION OF BILEH NEW
APPLICATION THOSE PROTESTS ALL
CARRY OVER ON THIS LEGISLATION
UNDER THE AMENDMENTS AGREED
TO WITH THE COMMITTEE WILL
PROVIDE THAT IF YOU ARE I'M
RE SUBMITTING A NEW LICENSE
TYPE LIKE YOU'RE CHANGING
FROM A BAR OR RESTAURANT
-- YOU THE THOSE PROTESTS
WILL NOT AUTOMATICALLY CARRY
OVER AND PEOPLE WILL HAVE TO
SUBMIT A NEW PROTEST TAILORED
TO THAT NEW -- LICENSE --
TYPE -- AND AND THEN FINALLY
SB NINE EIGHTY WILL --
-- WALLED MODIFY THE CURRENT
HEARING PROCESS TO PROVIDE
THAT IF MORE IF HEARING HAS
NOT OCCURRED WITHIN A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY DAYS OF A PROTEST
-- VAN THE PROTESTER
WILL HAVE TO RECONFIRM
THAT THEY STILL WANT TO PROCEED
WITH A PROTEST OTHERWISE THE
PROTEST WILL BE DEEMED WITHDRAWN
CITY CANNOT OF PROTESTERS AS
HANGS OUT THERE ARE FOREVER WITH
NO HEARINGS AYE SIR COLLEAGUES
THIS BILL IS A LITTLE BIT I
WON IT'S NOT A LITTLE BIT OF A
HODGEPODGE BIT IS A LIST OF SOME
VERY ODD TECHNICAL CHANGES
THAT WILL TANGIBLY BENEFIT SMALL
BUSINESSES TRYING TO OPEN IN
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE I WITH ME TO TESTIFY
-- IN PERSON IS I'VE BEEN GOING
THROUGH AND -- WITH THE SAN
FRANCISCO OFFICE OF ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT THE CITY
OF SAN FRANCISCO IS A SPONSOR
OF THE BILL -- THERE WAS A MIX
UP AND -- ON OUR END AND SO THE
THAT DID NOT MAKE IT INTO THE
ANALYSIS -- IN ADDITION A BY
PHONE WE'LL HEAR FROM BEN LYMAN
WHO REPRESENTS THE SAN FRANCISCO
BAR OWNERS ALLIANCE THANK YOU
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MISS
VAN HOUTEN'S YOU MAY BEGIN GOOD
MORNING AND AND THANK YOU TURNED
OUT MEMBERS -- BEEN BEEN OUT AND
ON BEHALF OF SAN FRANCISCO MAYOR
LONDON BREED HERE TO EXPRESS
OUR STRONG SUPPORT FOR SB NINE
EIGHTY CENTIMETERS LEGISLATION
WOULD MAKE A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
REFORMS TO CALIFORNIA'S ALCOHOL
LAWS IN ORDER TO SUPPORT SMALL
BUSINESSES AND ECONOMIC RECOVERY
STATEWIDE -- IN THE CITY AND
COUNTY OF SAN FRANCISCO THE
NIGHTLIFE SECTOR HAS BEEN A
MAJOR ECONOMIC DRIVER AND
IT WILL BE A CRITICAL PART
OF OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY
I'M PROUD OF THE PANDEMIC
R. THREE THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED NIGHTLIFE BUSINESSES
EMPLOYED OVER SIXTY FOUR
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND GENERATED
AN ESTIMATED SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN ANNUAL AND ECONOMIC
ECONOMIC IMPACT -- WHILE WE
HAVE SEEN EXCITING PROGRESS
IN OUR ECONOMIC RECOVERY IN
OUR CITY THE PANDEMIC HAS HAD
A DEVASTATING IMPACT ON THIS
SECTOR EMPLOYMENT IS STILL DOWN
TWENTY SEVEN PERCENT COMPARED
TO FEBRUARY TWENTY TWENTY
AND MANY OF OUR NIGHTLIFE
BUSINESSES FACE SUBSTANTIAL
UNPAID RENT AND OTHER DEBTS
THAT ARE STILL COMING TO YOU
AFTER BEING ACCRUED OVER THE
LAST TWO YEARS I'M CALIFORNIA'S
LIQUOR LICENSING LAWS CAN
MAKE IT EXTREMELY DIFFICULT
FOR BUSINESSES TO OPEN ADAPT
RELOCATE AND EXPAND THE MANY
PROVISIONS THAT THE CENTER
TALKED ABOUT EACH OF THEM
IT THESE REFORMS WILL HELP SAN
FRANCISCO'S NIGHTLIFE SECTOR
RECOVER -- BY HELPING BUSINESSES
OPEN UP MORE QUICKLY AND --
AND MORE NIMBLY SB NINE EIGHTY
IS A VITAL PACKAGE OF REFORMS TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES TO HELP
THE SECTOR THRIVE MOVING FORWARD
-- NIGHTLIFE BUSINESSES ARE AND
WILL CONTINUE TO BE CRITICAL
TO THE ECONOMIC RECOVERY OF
SAN FRANCISCO AND CITY STATE
WIDE AND IT IS INCUMBENT THAT
WE CUT RED TAPE AND STREAMLINE
PERMITTING PROCESS HE'S AT THE
STATE AND LOCAL LEVEL IN ORDER
TO DO SO -- THIS WILL THIS
BILL WILL DELIVER A SERIES OF
IMPORTANT AND OVERDUE REFORMS
TO HELP OUR CITY'S REBOUND
FROM THE PANDEMIC AND ENABLE
ENTREPRENEURS TO OPEN NEW AND
EXCITING SMALL BUSINESSES THAT
INVEST IN THE RECOVERY OF THEIR
COMMUNITIES I'M HAPPY ALSO
ANSWERING TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
ABOUT ANY OF THE PIECES OF THE
BILL AS WELL I WANT TO THANK
CENTER WIENER FOR HIS LEADERSHIP
ON THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION
AND AS WELL AS TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR ALL THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL REALLY APPRECIATE ALL THE
GOOD FEEDBACK AND DISCUSSION
-- AS WE WORKED ON THIS AND
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER VAN HOUTEN A MISTER
VAN -- MR BLACKMUN --
YOU MAY BEGIN YOUR ON THE LINE
AND THE DEPLOYMENT IF YOU
ARE ON THE LINE AND HAVE
NOT HAD YOUR NAME HEY COULD
YOU IF PRESSED ONE AND THEN
ZERO SO I MAY OPEN YOUR LINE
THEN AGAIN AFTER FIVE MINUTES
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
I'LL BE ABLE TO OPEN YOUR LINE
WE DO NOT HAVE MR CLINTON ON
THE MONTHS OKAY IF HE DOES
COME ON THE LINE PLEASE --
YOU KNOW LET ME KNOW BUT WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE WITH ANY
WITNESSES AND SUPPORT HERE IN
THIS ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD
IF YOU'RE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT
C. NOBODY -- COMING FORWARD
WILL -- NOW MOVE ON TO THE
WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE OR MISS
MODERATOR FEW POLICE PROPPED
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF S. B. NINE EIGHTY
PLEASE OPEN ALLIANCE A CALL THE
SUPPORT WITNESSES INDIVIDUALLY
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF
SB NINE AB IN A PRESS ONE IF
THAT THEIR -- AT THIS TIME
ONCE AGAIN HE WISHED TO COME
INTO THE PORT SB NINE EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE IN THE AREA
WE HAVE NO WITHIN THE QUEUE
AT THE THANK YOU MODERATOR
-- NOW WILL BE MOVING TO
-- HERE FROM -- OPPOSITION
-- I BELIEVE WE HAVE RYAN
FLANAGAN ON THE COASTLINE
IN MY READ -- JIMENEZ
-- HERE IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION MISTER
FLANAGAN YOU MAYBE GET
AND MR PLAN AGAIN IF YOU HAVE
NOT HAD YOUR NAME TAKEN YEAH
HAVE YOU PRESS ONE AT THAT
THEIR -- AT THIS TIME WE MAY
OPEN YOUR NINE AND AGAIN
THIS TO FIGHT AGAIN IF YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE END OF
I DO NOT HAVE THE STRUGGLING
TO GET ON THE PHONE
OKAY MISS JIMENEZ ARE YOU IN
THE ROOM PLEASE COME FORWARD
GOOD MORNING
-- THE SPECIAL AT
THANK YOU TO THE CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS MY TO HUMANISTS --
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL POLICY
ALLIANCE OVER FIFTY PUBLIC
HEALTH PUBLIC SAFETY AND
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA WE ARE HERE TODAY
TO OPPOSE SB NINE EIGHTEEN WE
REPRESENT LOW INCOME WORKING
CLASS NEIGHBORHOODS THAT BEAR
THE BRUNT OF ALCOHOL HARMS
EVERY DAY AGO HARMS CONTINUE
IN THE SAME HISTORICALLY
SEGREGATED AND DISENFRANCHISED
NEIGHBORHOODS THIS IS DIRECTLY
TIED TO OVER CONCENTRATION OF
ALCOHOL OUTLETS RESEARCH SHOWS
ON SALE OUTLETS NOT ONLY LIQUOR
STORES DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTS LOW INCOME BLACK
INDIGENOUS AND COMMUNITIES OF
COLORS OF COLOR MOST REGULATING
ALCOHOL DENSITY IS A PROTECTIVE
STRATEGY FOR NEIGHBORHOODS MANY
OF YOU REPRESENT IT IS ALREADY
EXTREMELY COMPLICATED AND NOT
ACCESSIBLE FOR COMMUNITIES TO
PROTEST AN ALCOHOL LICENSE IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITIES CANNOT
AFFORD LEGAL COUNSEL NOR CAN
THEY LEVERAGE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THAT MANY OF YOU
HERE TO HEAR TODAY BENEFIT FROM
TO FIGHT BACK AGAINST ALCOHOL
IN COMMUNITIES THE ONLY AVENUE
COMMUNITY HAS IS IS A. B. C.'S
LIMITED CAPACITY TO ADVOCATE
ON THEIR BEHALF WITH A FEW
OPPORTUNITIES TO PROTEST AN
ALCOHOL LICENSE ASSUMING THEY
CAN MANAGE TO OVERCOME THE
BUREAUCRACY OF THE PROCESS AS
YOU ALL KNOW DENYING AN ALCOHOL
LICENCE ON THE PROXIMITY TO
SCHOOLS CHURCHES AND YOUTH
ORIENTED LOCATIONS IS ALSO
VERY RARE VERY RARE APPLYING
FOR AN ALCOHOL LICENCE IS
TRENDING BUT AT WHAT COST DO WE
HAVE ANY DATA TO SHOW ALCOHOL
LICENSING LICENSES VIA SO
CALLED MODERN APPROACHES LIKE
SB NINE EIGHTY IS AN EFFECTIVE
STRATEGY THAT WILL BENEFIT
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WE DON'T
ON THE CONTRARY ACCORDING TO
CDPH OFFICE OF HEALTH EQUITY
HEALTH COMMUNITIES DATA AND
INDICATORS PROJECT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE QUOTE LIMITING
ALCOHOL OUTLET DENSITY THROUGH
THE USE OF REGULATORY AUTHORITY
LICENSING AND ZONING IS A
STRATEGY TO PREVENT DEATHS
AND HARMS ASSOCIATED WITH
EXCESSIVE ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION
QUOTE MULTIPLE STUDIES PROVIDE
EVIDENCE THAT HIGHER ALCOHOL
OUTLET DENSITY AND CLOSER
PROXIMITY TO ALCOHOL OUTLETS
OUTLETS IS POSITIVELY ASSOCIATED
WITH OUTCOMES LIKE EXCESSIVE
ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION AND ALCOHOL
RELATED HARMS LIKE INJURIES AND
VIOLENCE SB NINE NINE EIGHTY
DOES NOT MODERNIZE ALCOHOL
LICENSING PROCESS IT SEEKS
TO EXPEDITE PROLIFERATION OF
ALCOHOL DEPENDENCY UNDER THE
GUISE OF SUPPORTING SO SMALL
BUSINESSES AND REDEVELOPMENT
SUPPORTING THIS BILL ENABLES
A TOXIC CULTURE OF DEPENDING
ON ALCOHOL CONSUMPTION AT
THE EXPENSE OF COMMUNITY AND
RESEARCH THAT CLEARLY SHOWS
PROXIMITY AND AS AND ACT IN
EXCESS OF ALCOHOL OUTLETS IS
A RISK FACTOR FOR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS TO CLARIFY THERE
IS NO LACK OF NEW LICENSES IN
CALIFORNIA A. B. C. DENIES FEWER
THAN TEN EACH YEAR AND CONTINUES
TO GRANT THEM AN ALREADY OVER
CONCENTRATED AREAS WHERE YOU
STAND WITH PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SUPPORT OF FAIR AND ACCESSIBLE
PUBLIC PROCESS VOTE NO ON SB
NINE EIGHTY THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISS EMINENCE THIS I BELIEVE
MR FLANAGAN'S ON THE LINE
WHAT'S THAT IT WHAT TO GET
MISTER AND I THINK IN THIS
DEPLOYMENT IS IT PRESS ONE OF
THE GIRLS AT SCHOOL US HELLO
HE'S OFFER QUESTIONS YEAH
WE DO HAVE THE -- MR KLEIMAN ON
AT THE FRONT OKAY FAIR ENOUGH
GO AHEAD THE SUPPORT LINE IS
OPEN HI MY
NAME IS AND WHY AND AND I'M A
LOT OLDER DISTRICTS WHICH SHOWED
A RESTAURANT OWNER OFF THE
FOUNDER OF THE SEPARATIST OWNER
LANCASHIRE'S GROUP OF OVER FIVE
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS ARE OWNERS
IN THE CITY ITSELF WE'RE HERE
IN OUR VERY STRONG SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY I'M LOOKING TO SUBMIT
A COMMENT AND I DON'T THINK
THEY'RE FULLY CAPTURING WHAT
A NIGHTMARE THE ABC PROCESSES
FOR -- WELL MEETING ROLLINS
HEADED OFF MORTGAGES OWNERSHIP
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SUFFERED SO MUCH DURING
CORONA NINETEEN OCTOBER NINETEEN
VIRUS A CRISIS AND WE JUST NEED
HELP RIGHT NOW I PERSONALLY WAS
HELD UP WITH MY LICENSE FOR OVER
EIGHTEEN MONTHS THE TRANSFER
OF VERY FAIRLY SIMPLE TRANSFER
BY A SINGLE PROTESTER WHO
USED EVERY STEP OF THE PROCESS
TO JUST LEAD US DRY WITH MONEY
KNOWING FULL WELL THAT OUR
LICENSE RECOVERY PASS ANYWAY
DITION BUILDS NOT SEEK TO OPEN
THE FLOODGATES AND JUST FLUNG
PLACES LIKE CONFUSED IT IS A
VERY VERY PRACTICAL FIELD BASED
ON EXPERIENCE IT MYSELF AND
MANY MANY OTHER FARMERS INSTEAD
CALIFORNIA JUST CLEANING UP
SOME OF THE CODE TO MAKE IT MORE
PRACTICAL AND HAVE A GOVERNMENT
THAT WORKS WELL RIGHT
ONCE AGAIN AND SPEAKING IN VERY
STRONG SUPPORT THIS AND ALL THE
REST OF MY COMMENTS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WILL -- MISTER FLANAGAN
ARE YOU ON THE LINE
AND MR FLANAGAN IF YOU HAVE
NOT HAD YOUR NAME TAKEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
PHILLY MAPLE PUT YOUR LINE
ONCE AGAIN MISTER FLANAGAN
IF I MAY HAVE YOU PRESS
ONE AND THAT THERE
GOING TO KNOWING GONE OKAY
MODERATE IF YOU PLEASE PROP
INDIVIDUALS WAITING TO TESTIFY
IN OPPOSITION SB NINE EIGHTY
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES OF
CALL OPPOSITION WITNESSES
INDIVIDUALLY AND WE WILL
CONTINUE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT IN
OPPOSITION OF SB NINE EIGHTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO
AT THIS TIME MODERATOR IF YOU
WISH YEAH I'M GONNA GO WITH --
TO SOMEBODY THAT'S IN HERE IN
THE ROOM HERE FIRST AND THEN
YOU CAN CALL -- DELIGHTS SIR
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU THANK
YOU GERMAN DOT MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF
OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE IN OPPOSITION
TO THE BILL RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
A NO VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR ANYBODY
ELSE IN THE ROOM WISHING TO
TESTIFY MODERATOR POLICE BEGIN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
ONCE AGAIN LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OF S. P. NINETY D.
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO
LINE FIFTY FOUR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
ALL RIGHT HERE ANOTHER BELL
OKAY THANK YOU WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
AND THANKS TO OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS I DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
SEEING -- NONE CENTER WIENER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE --
I RESPECTFULLY ASK AND I WILL
THANK YOU SENATOR I DO WE HAVE
A MOTION ON SB NINE EIGHTY
THAT'S CORRECT SO WHAT WE'LL
DO A CENTER WIENER IS WILL SOON
AS WE GET A QUORUM WILL PUT
THIS BILL FORWARD I'M SORRY I
MISSED THAT THE OPPORTUNITY JUST
AFTERWARDS IF I MAY I KNOW THEY
WERE GOING OUT OF ARE YOU OKAY
WITH THAT YEAH I DID YOU WERE
TALKING TO SENATOR GLAZERS TO
TODD SO I DID YEAH RIGHT I SEE
YOUR HEADLIGHTS BUT YOU KNOW
I JUST WANNA SAY I YOU KNOW I
DO I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE SOME
OF THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
OUT FROM MONICA HUNT JUSTICE
AND THAT FATHER AND I HAD A
REALLY PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATION
AND WE'RE GOING TO DISCUSS THAT
OVER SATURATION BECAUSE IT'S
A CONCERN THAT I PERSONALLY
SHARE BUT YOU KNOW ALSO WANTED
TO KNOWLEDGE THE COMMENTS OF
THE GENTLEMAN THAT CALLED ABOUT
YOU KNOW THOSE THAT ARE WELL
INTENDED GOOD OPERATORS WHO HAVE
TO WAIT EIGHTEEN MONTHS THAT'S
ALSO UNACCEPTABLE SO CLEARLY
THERE'S SOME WORK TO BE DONE BUT
I DO BELIEVE THAT WE CAN FIND
OUT WHAT THE AUTHOR AND HE ALSO
WAS VERY OPEN TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION SO I WILL WITH THE
BILL THANK YOU WHEN APPROPRIATE
THANK YOU CENTER RUBIO
PARDON INTERNET INTERRUPTION
THE SECURITY TO HAVE BRIAN
FLANAGAN WHO HAS JUST ABOUT
I YOU KNOW I THINK OF THIS
FLANAGAN THE TIME HAS COME AND
PASSED SO I APPRECIATE YOU BEING
ON THE LINE BUT WE'RE MOVING
ON THE NEXT BILL WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE IT IS -- S. B. THIS FILE
ITEM THERE THIRTEEN ELEVEN
-- CENTREBOARD THIS IS GONNA BE
HANDLING THIS FOR CENTER WILL
SIR BORDERS THIS IS A S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YES
SIR THANK YOU PLEASE PROCEED
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HERE -- I
AM OBVIOUSLY NOT SENATOR SCOTT
WILK -- THE REPUBLICAN LEADER
IS INDISPOSED ON FILLING IN
FOR HIM AND I APPRECIATE THE
COMMENDATION -- CHAIRMAN SO
COLLEAGUES I AM PRESENTING
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN ON BEHALF OF SENATOR SCOTT
WILK THE BILL AMENDS THE PUBLIC
CONTRACT CODE TO PROHIBIT THE
STATE AGENCY FROM AWARDING A NO
BID CONTRACT ANY COMPANY THAT
HAS MADE A. B. HAS TO PAYMENT
ON BEHALF OF THE GOVERNOR IN
THE PRECEDING TWELVE MONTHS
CENTER WILK SIX TO ENSURE
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE IN THE
STATE'S PROCUREMENT PROCESS BY
ADDRESSING THE PERCEPTION OF
PAY TO PLAY THAT HAS DEVELOPED
FROM INCREASED USE OF NO BID
CONTRACTING FOR MARCH TWENTY
TWENTY THROUGH THE END OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE STATE AGENCIES
HAVE ENTERED INTO NO BID
CONTRACTS WORTH NEARLY TWELVE
BILLION DOLLARS FOR VARIOUS
PANDEMIC RELATED GOODS AND
SERVICES DURING THE SAME PERIOD
HAS TO PAYMENTS ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNOR SEARCHED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ALONE THERE WAS TWO
HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
IN BEHESHTI PAYMENTS COMPARED
WITH TWENTY NINETEEN WHEN
THAT AMOUNT WAS TWELVE POINT
ONE MILLION ON BEHALF OF THE
GOVERNOR AWARDING NO BID
CONTRACTS TO DONORS TO BE HAS
TO PAYMENTS IT'S CONCERNING
TO CENTER WILK AND HE BELIEVES
THIS TREND NEEDS TO BE CHECKED
REGARDING THE CONCERNS MENTIONED
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS SENATOR
WILK IS WILLING TO WORK ON
AMENDMENTS GOING FORWARD THAT
WOULD NUMBER ONE ALLOWED
NO BIG CONTRACTS ENTITIES THAT
HAVE BEEN MADE ABOUT HAS TO
PAYMENT I IF THE STATE AGENCY
HAS GONE THROUGH THE BIDDING
PROCESS IN LESS THAN THREE BIDS
OR PROPOSALS WERE RECEIVED OR
IF THE STATE AGENCY AND THE
D. D. G. S. AGREE THAT THE
CONTRACT ONLY BE FILLED BY
THE ENTITY THAT GAVE THE BEST
PAYMENT NUMBER TO REQUIRE THE
COMPANY CITING NO BIG CONTRACTS
ATTEST TO THE FACT THAT
THEY HAVE NOT MADE A HAS TO
PAYMENT IN PREVIOUS TWELVE
MONTHS THIS WOULD ADDRESS
THE CONCERN WITH THE CURRENT
DELAY IN REPORTING FOR QUIRE
MENTS WITNESSES TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OR TRENT LANG PRESIDENT
OF THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY
CAMPAIGN IN SCOTT KAUFMAN
FROM HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU CHAIRMAN
THANK YOU SIR WILK --
IN THIS WAY ARE YOU ON THE
OKAY SO -- TRENT LANG
I BELIEVE YOU'RE ON THE
PHONE LINE HOPEFULLY WE
HAVE MORE SUCCESS WITH YOU
YES HELLO I I ACTUALLY
CAME ON WHICH TO BUILD
IS THIS ONE OF THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER WILL
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH I COULD
MORNING AT YOUR DOT MEMBERS
THANKS FOR THE CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY CAMPAIGN LIKE TAKE THAT
ORDER OF WILL FOR OFFERING THAT
SUPPORT BILL AND DINNER PARTY
IS PRESENTING ITS -- IT'S NOT
OFTEN THAT I GET THE SAME TIGHT
IS POWER DARKEST BUT THIS IS
A GOOD BILL TO DO IT ON TOP
I WANT TO START BY SAYING THAT
IN GENERAL NO BID CONTRACT OR
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE AVOIDED
WHENEVER POSSIBLE BECAUSE IT'S
HARD TO GET AFFECTED IF NOBODY
ELSE IS BIDDING ESPECIALLY
WHEN THE CONTRACTOR KNOWS THAT
THAT'S WHY GENERAL LARGE NO
BID CONTRACT WILL OFTEN RAISE
EYEBROWS WITH THE PUBLIC BUT
WHEN MULTI MILLION DOLLAR NO
BID CONTRACT WERE GIVEN TO
COMPANIES THAT GAVE LARGE BEHALF
THE PAYMENT ON BEHALF OF AN
ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT'S WHEN
THEY'RE GOING TO BE REAL PUBLIC
PERCEPTION PROBLEMS THAT DIDN'T
MAKE MANY VOTERS LOSE CONFIDENCE
IN THE GOVERNMENT THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL TO BAN AWARDING NO
BID CONTRACT INTO THE THAT
GATE THEY HAVE TO PAYMENTS ON
BEHALF GOVERNMENT PASSED BOTH
MONTH IS SO IMPORTANT AT THE
COMMITTEE NOW THIS DID RATE
THEM IMPORTANT ISSUES WITH THE
BILL WOULD PRINT SUCH AS THAT
THERE ARE TIMES WHEN THE ONLY
COMPANY THAT ONLY COMPLICATE
THE HELP IS CAPABLE OF FILLING
THE CONTRACTOR WHEN THERE IS
A COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS
AND TO WORK WE QUALIFIED FIFTH
THESE CONCERNS THAT SHOULD AND
CAN BE ADDRESSED WE BELIEVE
-- BUT WHEN THEY'RE ACTUALLY
COMPLETELY FULFILL THE CONTRACT
TO HAPPEN GIVEN BENEFIT PAYMENTS
AT MY CONCERN THAT THE PUBLIC
EVEN AND ESPECIALLY DURING
EMERGENCY CRIMES LIKE THE CO
WITH NINETEEN AND THAT MAKES
PUBLIC CONFIDENCE WILL BE
GREATLY ENHANCED IF THE STATE
TAKES A LITTLE EXTRA TIME THE TO
GO THROUGH A SPED UP COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS OR GIVE THE
NO BID CONTRACT A COMPANY
THAT HAS MADE LARGE BEHEST THE
PAYMENTS I WOULD LIKE TO AFTER
I VOTE TO MOVE THE SUPPORT
BILL FORWARD TO GIVE TIME
FOR UP AND OTHER STAKEHOLDERS
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR IN
THE COMMITTEE TO WORK UP THE
AMENDMENTS NEEDED TO INSURE THAT
NO CONTRACT CAN BE GIVEN IN THE
BEHALF OF THE COMPANY IS THE
ONLY OPTION AS THE COMMITTEE
RAISED CONCERNS ABOUT WHILE
STILL FULFILLING THE PRIMARY
INTENT TO INCREASE PUBLIC
CONFIDENCE BY BARRING IT FROM
THERE ARE IN FACT OTHER OPTIONS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER LANG --
MISTER KAUFMAN FROM WHY
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
AND MISTER CARPENTER IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO PRESS ONE AND
THAT ZERO WILL BE ABLE TO OPEN
YOUR LINE ONCE AGAIN MISTER
COFFIN IF YOU WOULD PRESS ONE
OF THE DETAILS YOU CAN OPEN
YOUR MIND ONE MOMENT PLEASE
MISTER KAUFMAN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME YES
WE CAN THANK YOU VERY
MUCH -- BETTER PAYMENTS OR
DONATIONS FOR CARE PREPARED FOR
GOVERNMENTAL PURPOSES THEY'RE
SPECIFICALLY REQUESTED BY
ELECTED OFFICIALS OFTEN FROM
COMPANIES WITH BUSINESSES BEFORE
THE STATE AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN MILLION
WITH DONATED AT THE BEHEST OF
THE GOVERNOR THAT COMPARED TO
JUST TWELVE POINT ONE MILLION IN
TWENTY NINETEEN THE LOS ANGELES
TIMES NOTED THAT MANY OF THESE
DONORS HAVE OTHER BUSINESS
BEFORE THE GOVERNOR RECEIVE
NO BIG GOVERNMENT CONTRACT OR
LAST YEAR OR SEEKING FAVORABLE
APPOINTMENT ON IMPORTANT STATE
PORT WHICH THE TIMES NOTED GREAT
THE PARENTS OF A PAY TO PLAY
SYSTEM SENATE BILL THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN WOULD AMEND THE
PUBLIC CONTRACT CODE TO PROHIBIT
A STATE AGENCY FROM AWARDING A
NO BID CONTRACT THE COMPANY THAT
MADE A HEFTY PAYMENT ON BEHALF
OF THE GOVERNOR IN THE PRECEDING
TWELVE MONTHS THAT WOULD HELP
ADDRESS PERCEPTION OF PAY TO
PLAY STEMMING FROM THE INCREASE
IN USE THAT SECRETIVE NO BID
CONTRACTING ALSO AT AGE EIGHT
HE HASN'T HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO
REVIEW THE AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN PROPOSED TO ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THE COMMITTEES CONCERNED WITH
THIS BILL AND H. JTA REMAINED
IN SUPPORT I ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY HERE IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY IN THE
ROOM WISHING TO TESTIFY
SEEING NONE OF MODERATOR --
CAN WE OPEN THE TELECONFERENCE
ROOMS AT THIS POINT TIME TO SEE
WHO WANTS TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF
YOU WISH TO COMMENT FURTHER SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHAT TO GET IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT TO SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE IN THE THIRD LINE FIFTY
SEVEN LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD YES THIS IS SURELY
SHOWING UP BEYOND THE STATE
COORDINATOR FOR CALIFORNIA
THE MONEY IN ORDER THAT THE
THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND ALSO
CONSTITUENTS MENTOR DOT ECHO
FIVE FORTY FIVE DEVIDED
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
ONE MOMENT PLEASE ALSO A
MEMBER OF CALIFORNIA CLEAN
MONEY IN SUPPORT OF THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
ONE MOMENT FOR NEXT BY MEMBERS
MY THIRTY EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
MY NAME IS DAVID SCHMIDT IT
WAS JUST GO ON HERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
ON THE PORT S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
ONE FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THIS IS NANCY NASA FELL OUT
THOUGH I'M NOT THE ONLY CURE
COORDINATOR WITH HELP WHEN
YOU MANY CAMPAIGN SUPPORT
OF FIFTY FIFTY SIXTY SEVEN
MY FORTY SEVEN DIVIDED
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THANK FORTY SEVEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN HE MAY BE
ON YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD
WE WILL MOVE ON DEADLINE
FIFTY FOUR I'M SORRY YOUR
YEAH HI MY NAME IS THE FIRST
OF THE FIVE YEARS UP TO
THE OAKLAND CALIFORNIA FOR ME
VERY OFTEN FAKE COMMITTEE RABBIT
FLUFF AND BEEF ALAMEDA COUNTY
THAT'D COMMITTEE LOG THAT
ALLOCATED -- STEP FIFTY FOURTH
BOB UP AT THE THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN THANK YOU
MY FIFTY EIGHT YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS CLIFF PAPA ON BEHALF
OF GOVERNMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
I'M THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BENEFIT TO STEP NâNG
QUESTIONS AS YOU PUT YOUR
CHAPTER OF THE ACLU WILL HAVE
YOUR YOUR COORDINATOR FOR
AMNESTY INTERNATIONAL TODAY
AND HERE'S ALL ONCE YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN NO PATIENT PLACE THANK YOU
THANK YOU TO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
THE
BUT TO GET MY FIFTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN MAY GO AHEAD
I
HAD NO RESPONSE FROM
MY FIFTY TWO NO FURTHER
SUPPORT IN THE QUEUE AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU MODERATOR
HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FALL THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE
WHO'S IN THE ROOM THAT ONCE
TESTIFIED IN OPPOSITION TO
U. S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
C. NONE NONE WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY BE THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR PLEASE PROCEED
THANK YOU MEDICARE AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU MAY
PRESS ONE AT THAT ZERO AT
THE TIME WHAT BEGAN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
THE THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE
WE HAVE NO COMMENT
INTERVIEW AT THIS TIME
OKAY THANK YOU
SO WHY WOULD I WANT TO
THANK THE SUPPORT OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING
THIS DISCUSSION BACK TO THE
MEMBERS ANYBODY WISHING TO
WOULD ADDRESS THIS BILL CENTER
ARCHULETA YEAH THANK YOU MR --
YOU MIGHT HAVE TO SEND THIS
QUESTION TO THE EFFORTS THAT
YOU HAVE ON THE LINE SENATOR MY
QUESTION IS WHEN THE BETTING IT
GETS TO BE AT -- ONE OR TWO
AND THEY HAD MENTIONED THAT
THERE WOULD BE OTHER OPTIONS
WOULD YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THE
OTHER OPTION WOULD BE IN THE
EVENT THERE WOULD BE THIS WOULD
NOT BE SUFFICIENT BUILDING
THAT WE WERE ALL LOOKING FOR
YOU GOT THREE FOUR FIVE SEVEN
BIDS IN THIS CASE IT ON B. TWO
ONE WHAT ARE THE OTHER OPTIONS
WALKERS THROUGH THAT THANK YOU
IN AND OF COURSE I'M NOT IN A
POSITION TO BE ABLE TO ANSWER
THAT SO IF I IF I MAY BE ABLE
TO -- TO REFER THIS TO
DETERRENT MISTER LANG YES MISTER
LANG FROM OUT OF THE MONEY
CAMPAIGN THIS RULING HI YES
WOULD YOU HIRE THIS QUESTION A
YES THANK YOU CAN HEAR ME NOW
YES YES YES WEEKEND DID YOU
HEAR THE QUESTION MISTER LANG I
DID YES THEY DID YEAH THANK YOU
THAT'S VERY GOOD QUESTION WHAT
WHAT WE ARE POSING AS
AMENDMENTS WOULD BE THAT IN
THE CASE WHERE A COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS -- WAS
WAS TAKEN WAS WAS DONE AND
THERE WAS ONLY ONE OR TWO
IT IN THAT CASE THE NO BID
CONTRACT COULD BE GRANTED TO
THE COMPANY EVEN IF THEY GAVE
UP THEY HAVE TO TAKE THAT -- OR
IF IF THERE'S A DETERMINATION
MADE THAT THAT THE COMPANY WAS
THE ONLY ONE THAT COULD FULFILL
THE CONTRACT THERE ARE CASES
LIKE THAT THEN AGAIN THEY SHOULD
BE ALLOWED TO HAPPEN NO BID
CONTRACT IN THAT CASE EVEN IF
THEY GAVE BEHALF PAYMENT BECAUSE
THEY WOULD BE THE ONLY OPTION
WHAT WE BELIEVE THOSE OF MEN
SHOULD BE SHOULD BE MADE UP BUT
WE THINK THE CORE OF THE BILL
SAY THAT IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS AFTER YOU'VE DONE THE
COMPETITIVE PROCESS OR OR NOT
THAT IN THOSE CASES THE --
NO BID CONTRACTS SHOULD NOT
BE ALLOWED FROM THE FROM
MEDICAID MR FROM A COMMENT
SO WHAT WE'RE SAYING IF THE
EXPERTISE THE NECESSITY THE
EMERGENCY -- WOULD OVERRIDE THE
BEHEST THEN -- THAT WOULD BE
LOOKED AT THE QUALIFICATIONS
IN THE BACKGROUND AND HISTORY
OF THE BETTER THAT CORRECT
IF IF THERE WERE NOT OTHER
-- FOR THE MAIN OPERATOR BECAUSE
IT WOULD NOT TAKE EFFECT RIGHT
TO IT IF IF IF THERE WAS A
YEAH THAT THE TENTATIVE BIDDING
PROCESS AND AND AND THE
COMPANY GAVE THE PERHAPS WAS THE
WAS THE ONLY DOCTOR ONE ONLY
TWO OPTIONS THEN THREE GIVEN
THE NO BID CONTRACT THEY WERE
THE BEST OPTION IN THAT CASE WE
JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THERE
WILL THAT OTHER OP IT SHOULD
BE LOOKED AT IF THERE ARE OTHER
OPTIONS OTHER THAN THE ONE THAT
GAVE THE PAST BIG A PAYMENT
AND THAT WILL GIVE THE PUBLIC
MORE CONFIDENCE IN THE PROCESS
OF DOING THAT WE NOW TO THE
ELEMENTS THAT WOULD -- I GUESS
MAKE IT AT SECURE TRUST TO BOOK
IT WOULD BE THE HISTORY THE
THE STATUS OF THAT PARTICULAR
COMPANY AND THE REPUTATION AND
ON OR NOT -- I WOULD IMAGINE
THAT WOULD ALL COME INTO PLAY
YEP WHEN YOU WHEN YOU HAVE LOOK
AT OTHER OPTIONS ABSOLUTELY
THOSE THINGS ALL DEFINITELY COME
INTO PLAY THAT GUIDED ME WIN A
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS AND
ONLY ONE OR TWO AND THEY MAY
STILL BE CHOSEN JUST WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE IT'S NOT SITUATION
WHERE -- THE THE PUBLIC SEES
THAT THAT THE COMPANY THEY
GAVE A LARGE THAT HAS -- WAS
WAS CHOSEN AND THERE DIDN'T
SEEM TO BE A REASON THERE WAS
NO COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS
WENT HEY LOOK AT THE THESE
THREE OR FOUR OTHERS THAT THE
PUBLIC WILL FILL THAT BOX AT
IN THE APPLE RAISES CONCERNS
WITH THE PUBLIC I THINK WE'VE
SEEN AND -- THAT'S WHAT WE WHAT
THE STILL ADDRESSING THIS BILL
AFTER MENDING MAKE SURE THAT THE
CASES THAT YOU DESCRIBE WOULD
BE COVERED LET'S LOOK LET ME
JUST POINT OUT OF THE AMENDMENTS
TAKEN SO FAR IT WE CAN'T
TAKE A MEMBERS HERE IN THIS
MEETING TODAY THERE'S ANOTHER
MEETING ELECTIONS MEETING
TOMORROW DO NOT TAKE CARE OF
THOSE EMERGENCY PROVISIONS
MMHM YOUR VENTURE MY
QUESTION THANK YOU
-- ANY OTHER QUESTIONS
CENTER GLAZER
YEAH THANK YOU JERRY DIED --
YOU KNOW THE MOTIVATION BEHIND
THIS BILL IS IS ONE IN WHICH
I -- YOU KNOW GENERAL TERMS
SUPPORT -- I I THINK THAT THE
AUTHORS -- EFFORTS TO TRY TO
-- ELEVATE THESE THESE CHOICES
ARE AND TO TRY TO ELIMINATE
CONFLICT OF INTERESTS ARE
GOOD MOTIVATIONS AND IN THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS
-- THESE TYPES OF THINGS ARE
ONES IN WHICH I SUPPORT --
BUT I'M HAVING TROUBLE WITH
THIS BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN
BECAUSE OF A KEY ELEMENT TO IT
AND THAT'S THIS ISSUE OF IN AN
EMERGENCY IN AN EMERGENCY --
WE ALL WANNA TRY TO ELIMINATE
CONFLICTS NINE BILLS TO DO
JUST THAT THIS YEAR BUT IN AN
EMERGENCY YOU DON'T HAVE THE
LUXURY -- THAT ONE WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS THREE BIDS SIX CETERA
-- AND I KNOW THAT ONE OF
THE QUESTIONS BEFORE US IS
THIS ISSUE OF ACCOUNTABILITY
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THESE CHOICES
-- AND I WOULD SAY THAT THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
LEARNED THROUGH THIS PROCESS
WITH THIS EMERGENCY AND AS THIS
ADMINISTRATION IS THAT THERE
HAS BEEN ACCOUNTABILITY HOUSE
UP WELL WE AS THE LEGISLATURE
HAVE TO APPROVE THE MONEY
-- FOR THESE BIDS TO BE PAID
SO THERE IS A CHECK WITHIN THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS FOR THOSE
CHOICES I NUMBER TWO
-- IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE THE
GOVERNOR WAS SUBJECT TO RECALL
FOR HOW HE CONDUCTED HIMSELF
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND WE
KNOW THE RESULTS OF THAT BUT
THAT WAS AN ACCOUNTABILITY
TEST FOR THE DECISIONS HE MADE
IN THIS EMERGENCY AND FINALLY
HE'S GOING TO BE ON THE BALLOT
AND AND JUST A FEW WEEKS --
AND THEY'LL BE ANOTHER ANOTHER
ACCOUNTABILITY TEST FOR HIM IN
TERMS OF HOW HE HAS DONE DO I
LIKE TO SEE THIS TYPE OF OF OF
CLOSE LINKAGE BETWEEN OF THE HAS
THE PAYMENT AT A NO BID CONTRACT
NOW NO BUT IF THE BILL BEFORE
US TODAY SAID LET'S ELIMINATE
THE HAS TO PAYMENTS OKAY WELL
I'M INTERESTED IN MAYBE SUPPORT
A BILL LIKE THAT LET'S ELIMINATE
THE HAS TO PAYMENTS IF WE THINK
THAT'S THE CORROSIVE EFFECT NOW
THERE'S A LOT OF DOWNSIDES TO
THAT TO IN TERMS OF THE CHARITY
WORK THAT'S DONE BY PEOPLE
AND AND AND AND AND I ENTITIES
THAT WE HAVE BENEFITTED FROM
CERTAINLY DURING THIS PANDEMIC
AND DURING THIS EMERGENCY AND
THE RECORD COULD REFLECT A LOT
OF THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS WHAT
THEY ARE AND WHERE THEY HAVE
GONE BECAUSE IT'S ALL PART
OF THE PUBLIC RECORD PART OF
THE STANDARDS FOR THE HAS TO
PAYMENT IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
REPORT IT WOULD THEN NOT SIX
MONTHS NOT THREE MONTHS BUT
THIRTY DAYS SO ONCE AGAIN THERE
IS SOME TRANSPARENCY IN THIS
SPACE DOES IT MEAN THAT WE'VE
ELIMINATED THE CLOSE THE
APPEARANCE OF CONFLICT NO WE
HAVEN'T THIS BILL TRIES TO GET
TRIES TO GET TO THAT SPACE
BUT I THINK IT'S BECAUSE OF
THE FACT THAT IT'S AN EMERGENCY
THAT MAKES ME GIVE PAUSE I'D
LIKE TO SEE SOME COMMON GROUND
IN THIS SPACE THAT I CAN WEEK
THREAD THE NEEDLE A LITTLE
BIT BETTER THAN WHAT WHAT'S
BEFORE US TODAY BUT BECAUSE
IT'S THE BILL THAT'S BEFORE
US TODAY I'M AB RELUCTANTLY
I'M NOT GOING TO BE SUPPORTING
CENTER BAKER THANK YOU
YES I THINK MY COLLEAGUE
SENATOR GLAZERS MADE A LOT
OF THE AT POINTS I WANTED TO
MAKE I GUESS CERTAINLY GIVES
ME PAUSE WE'RE GOOD FRIENDS
WITH THE A CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN
COVER CALIFORNIA OTHERS WHO
ARE THE GOOD GOVERNMENT GROUPS
ARE ON IN SUPPORT BUT AT
I DO YOU WANT TO COME BACK TO
WORK CENTER GLAZER SAID ABOUT AN
EMERGENCY AND WEBER STATE ALLOW
THE POINTS HE SAID THERE BUT
I THINK THE RELEVANT AND AND
EVEN THE SUPPORTERS HAVE RAISED
A NUMBER OF CONCERNS IS IN
HOUSES DOES WITH THE CURRENT
BILL I DO WANNA SAY FOR BEST
A PAYMENTS ITSELF YOU KNOW THE
IMPLICATION IS THAT THESE ARE
THESE ARE NEFARIOUS PAYMENTS
I'D SAY IN MY VIEW I SAY WE
DON'T WANT TO DISCOURAGE THEM
YOU KNOW THERE IS TWO HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS OF
BEST A PAYMENTS THAT WAS DURING
THE PANDEMIC THERE WAS TENS OF
MILLIONS OF THIS YEAR HEALTH
FOUNDATION THE CDC FOUNDATION
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE EVEN
FOR THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE
THOSE WERE USED FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH ADDS TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE
TO USE MASKS TO REDUCE THE
SPREAD OF COVERT NINETEEN SO
-- TO IT YOU KNOW IMPLY THAT
THOSE ARE ALL NEGATIVE MATT
I'D SAY WE ACTUALLY DON'T
WANT TO DISCOURAGE THEM IN
THE END -- AGAIN IN THE CASE
OF EMERGENCY WHICH THESE
PAYMENTS CAME IN AND WHEN THESE
CONTRACTS AWARDED SO THOSE ARE
THINGS THAT GIVE ME PAUSE TO --
TO TO COME OUT AND SUPPORT THE
BILL CENTER
RUBIO THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND ALONG THE LINES OF
BOTH OF MY COLLEAGUES WHO JUST
SPOKE I BELIEVE GOOD GOVERNMENT
IS IMPORTANT TRANSPARENCY
AND ACCOUNTABILITY IS REALLY
IMPORTANT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE -- MY COMMUTE BE TAKEN
CARE OF IN CASE IN CASE OF AN
EMERGENCY AND I THINK IT'S BEEN
DISCUSSED HERE WE CANNOT LEAVE
OUR COMMUNITIES TO FEND FOR
THEMSELVES WHEN THERE IS A TRUE
EMERGENCY AND I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THAT CONVERSATION HAPPENED
BOB AGAIN I WILL ALSO PAUSE ON
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE CANNOT JUST
SAY -- WE CAN'T DO ANYTHING
IN CASE OF AN EMERGENCY WE
AND ALL THAT THAT THIS WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED TIMES UNUSUAL
CIRCUMSTANCES AS MY COLLEAGUE
STATED A LOT OF THE BEHEST
HE HAS A PAYMENTS WERE BASED
ON ON THE NEED AT THE TIME TO
HELP OUR COMMUNITIES -- WITH
-- PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES BUT
AGAIN I WOULD LIKE MY COMMUNITY
TO BE TAKEN CARE OF IN CASE
OF AN EMERGENCY AND THIS WILL
LEAVE OUR COMMUNITIES PRETTY
MUCH TELL TO DRY CELL FOR
THAT I WILL ALSO STAFF THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY
SIR BORDERS WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YES THANK YOU AND
I APPRECIATE TO -- THE -- --
THE DISCUSSION ON THESE POINTS
OBVIOUSLY I'M DISADVANTAGED
-- THIS NOT BEING MY BILL --
IN NOT HAVING -- THE INTIMATE
KNOWLEDGE OF THE INTENT OF THE
AUTHOR SO -- I HOPE I DON'T
OVERSTEP MYSELF -- BY SAYING THE
FOLLOWING I THINK WHAT IS
THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO HERE
IS -- INJECT -- HIGHER
LEVEL OF TRANSPARENCY AND
CREDIBILITY TO THE PROCESS
WE KNOW THAT IN TWENTY TWENTY
IN THE MIDST OF THE PANDEMIC
I DURING THE DECLARED STATE
OF EMERGENCY BASS PAYMENTS
PROBABLY USE FOR THE BETTERMENT
OF COMMUNITIES THE BETTERMENT
OF THE STATE'S AND IT'S ABOUT
THE STATE AND ITS RESIDENTS
SO I THINK I DON'T THINK WE
SHOULD FOCUS TOO MUCH ON THE
STATE OF EMERGENCY AS
-- THE BASELINE FOR A BILL LIKE
THIS GETTING TO SENATOR GLAZERS
POINT THAT THIS ACTUALLY
CAN BEING A BENEFICIAL PROCESS
THAT ENCOURAGES FOLKS TO STILL
ODD -- DIRECT PHILANTHROPIC OR
CHARITABLE DOLLARS TO DESIGNATED
-- BENEFICIARIES BECAUSE WE
ALL BENEFIT FROM THAT FROM
THAT PROCESS WHICH WANT TO
DO SO IN A WAY THAT DOES NOT
CONFLATE THE BIDDING PROCESS
WITH THE CHARITABLE DONATION
AND SO I THINK WHAT I HEARD
FROM CENTER GLAZER AND OTHERS
IS THAT THIS WAS A UNIQUE MOMENT
IN TIME DURING THE DECLARE STATE
OF EMERGENCY AND I WOULD
VENTURE TO SAY THAT THE AUTHOR
WOULD BE WILLING TO CONSIDER
ON ADDITIONAL MODIFICATIONS
TO THIS BILL TO ALLEVIATE SOME
OF THOSE CONCERNS BUT AS WE ALL
KNOW THAT A BILL LIKE THIS CAN'T
STOP OR DIES AND I AND
I WOULD I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
CENTER WELCOME TO ENGAGE FURTHER
WITH THE COMMITTEE SPECIFICALLY
ON THE EMERGENCY CALCULATION
BECAUSE IF THERE IS A DECLARE
STATE OF EMERGENCY MAYBE THERE
NEEDS TO BE FLEXIBILITY MORE
FLEXIBILITY INHERENT IN THE
PROCESS BUT OUTSIDE OF THOSE
UNIQUE I AND -- EXISTENCE
CIRCUMSTANCES MAYBE WE NEED
TO HAVE A MORE TRANSPARENT
IN BASELINE APPROACH SO IN
IN CLOSING COLLEAGUES I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK ON BEHALF OF
SENATOR WILK THE OPPORTUNITY
TO MOVE THIS BILL FORWARD
WITH POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS AND
ADDITIONAL DISCUSSIONS WORKING
WITH THE CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE
TO ADDRESS THE THE VERY SPECIFIC
ISSUE THAT NOT JUST ONE TO
FOUR MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE
BROUGHT UP NOW THAT WE'VE
NARROWED THE ISSUE ARE AND THE
ROB I THINK WE COULD RESOLVE IT
SO WITH YOUR -- WITH YOUR
PERMISSION FOR THIS BILL TO MOVE
FORWARD TODAY -- ON BEHALF OF
CENTER WILK HE WOULD CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE CONSIDERATION
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER AYE
VOTE WITH INTENDED AMENDMENTS
FORTHCOMING THANK YOU SENATOR
GORGEOUS -- THIS IS WE HAVE A
QUORUM WILL I GET A MOTION ON
THAT AND GET A VOTE -- BEFORE
THAT -- CENTER GLAZER J. DOT I
KNOW THAT TO THAT CONVERSATION
IS AND IT'S ALL JUST ASK UP A
FACTUAL QUESTION TO THE CHAIR --
THIS BILL IS -- HAS
BEEN AS I RECALL DOUBLE REFERRED
AND THAT MY RECOLLECTION IS THE
NEXT HEARING ON THIS BILL WERE
TO MOVE OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE
THIS TOMORROW THAT'S TOMORROW
AND THAT CAN YOU JUST CONFIRM
THAT THAT'S THAT THAT'S THE
CASE CHAIR THAT'S THE CASE OKAY
BECAUSE THAT THAT OBVIOUSLY
LIMITS THE ABILITY TO DO WHAT
TO DO MORE TO DISABILITIES
THANK YOU AND IF IT THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THAT TO MY
ATTENTION -- THERE IS ALSO
THE POSSIBILITY OF -- --
HOSTILE AMENDMENTS AND IF THERE
IS A FORCIBLE AMENDMENT TO BE
INJECTED INTO THIS I'M CERTAIN
THAT THE U. S. SENATOR STAFF
WOULD WELCOME THAT IF IT ALLOWS
FOR THIS BILL TO MOVE FORWARD IN
THE FASHION THAT WOULD ALLOW FOR
THAT AMENDMENT TO BE REVIEWED
IN THE NEXT COMMITTEE TOMORROW
WELL THAT'S PROCESS WE HAVE A
PROCESS SO -- I DON'T I DON'T
SEE THAT HAPPENING BUT --
UP BRING IT ON I GUESS WE'LL
JUST HAVE TO -- PRESENT WHICH
CAN I -- YEAH DO YOU MIND IF
I CONSULT WITH -- THE CENTER
STAFF BEFORE THE VOTE OCCURS
JUST THERE'S NOT A VOTE RIGHT
NOW YOU GOT PLENTY OF TIME I'M
LEAVING FOR JUDICIAL JUST ONE
THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
AND I WILL I WILL I WILL
CONCLUDE FOR THE SECOND FINAL
TIME MEASURE YOU -- THAT
-- IF WHEN THIS WHEN THE
COMMITTEE IS FULLY CONSTITUTED
IN THIS BILL IS VOTED UPON
-- I WOULD MAKE THE HUMBLE
RECOMMENDATION TO TO THE AUTHOR
THAT THERE BE AN EXCLUSION
DURING STATES OF EMERGENCY
THANK YOU
OKAY AT THIS POINT TIME WE'RE
MOVING ON TO -- ITEM NUMBER
TEN THAT'S S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE ANOTHER BILL BY A
CENTER WILL WHO IS NOT ABLE
TO BE HERE TO PRESENT ON HIS
OWN BEHALF AND SO WE HAVE
-- SENATOR PACKARD THIS COULD
BE PRESENTING FOR CENTER WILK
POLICE RECEIVED CENTER BACKER
THANK YOU THAT MEMBERS OF
THE HALF OF CENTER WORK I
WILL BE PRESENTING SENATE
BILL AT TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
THAT IN THIS BILLS INTRODUCED
REQUIRED OVERSIGHT HEARING BY
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE PRIOR TO THE RENEWAL
OR EXTENSION ANOTHER OVERSIGHT
PIECE OF A NO BID STATE CONTRACT
WORTH TWENTY FIVE MILLION OR
MORE SIR WILL CAUSE AGREED TO
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE'S PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS WHICH REMOVES THE
REQUIREMENT FOR AN OVERSIGHT
HEARING INSTEAD IT REQUIRES
THAT FOR NO BID CONTRACT OF
TWENTY FIVE MILLION OR MORE
ENTERED UPON WERE AFTER NEXT
YEAR ESTATE AGENCY SHALL
SUBMIT TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE INFORMATION
REGARDING THE TERMS AND
CONDITIONS OTHER POSTS EXTENSION
OR RENEWAL OF THE CONTRACT
THIS IS BY THE COMMITTEE
WITH FLEXIBILITY OR WHETHER
TO HOLD AN OVERSIGHT THAT
BASED ON THE -- IN OVERSIGHT
BASED ON THE INFORMATION
CONTAINED IN THE CONTRACTS
THEIR WORK IS CONCERNED ABOUT
THE INCREASED PROCUREMENT OF
THESE NO BID CONTRACTS MUST
ENSURE THE LEGISLATURE HAS THE
INFORMATION NECESSARY AS WE
JUST DISCUSSED FOR ADEQUATE
OVERSIGHT UP TO PROVIDE
AB TESTIMONY SUPPORTER TRENT
LANG AGAIN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
CLEAN MONEY CAMPAIGN AND SCOTT
KAUFMAN BUDGET DIRECTOR OF
THE HOWARD JARVIS TAXPAYERS
ASSOCIATION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR OF MR LYING
-- PLEASE PROCEED
OKAY THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
AGAIN AT YOUR GARDEN MEMBERS
PRESS LIKE BUTTON COPY MONEY
CAMPAIGN AGAIN -- LOOK LIKE THAT
THEY CAN -- WILL PROFFERING --
THIS ALSO IMPORTANT BILL AND
AFTER THANK YOU FOR PRESENTING
IT -- WE BELIEVE THIS RIGHT
THE OVERSIGHT IS VERY IMPORTANT
FOR GOOD GOVERNMENT -- AS
AS AS WE DISCUSSED THE NO
BID CONTRACT MAY SOMETIMES
BE NECESSARY -- ESPECIALLY
DURING EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
LIKE -- -- THE PANDEMIC --
THE LACK OF A COMPETITIVE
BIDDING PROCESS CAN DIFFER
DRAMATICALLY INCREASE PETROL
FOR UNNECESSARY ADDITIONAL FOX
CALIFORNIA THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL AS I UNDERSTAND THAT IS
BEING -- -- -- -- PROPOSED TO
BE AMENDED BY THE COMMITTEE
-- TO PROVIDE THE INFORMATION
THAT THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE
BUDGET COMMITTEE NEEDS TO
CONSIDER WHETHER TO REVIEW
RENEWAL OF A NO BID CONTRACT
SO THEY CAN DECIDE WITHOUT
THE THEY HAVE HEARINGS ABOUT
THAT IS A VERY POSITIVE STEP
UP TO PROVIDE -- THE POTENTIAL
FOR ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT WHEN
NECESSARY OF NO BID CONTRACT
BILLS AND SO WE THEREFORE
RESPECT REQUEST MY BOAT THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISTER LANCASTER
KAUFMAN FEEL FREE TO BEGIN
MISTER KAUFMAN ARE YOU ON THE
LINE I AM CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH PLEASE PROCEED OKAY
-- DID BUILD HOPE ANYONE WOULD
HAVE BEEN THE PUBLIC CONTRACT
CODE REQUIRE THAT FOR A NO
BID CONTRACT THE TWENTY FIVE
MILLION OR MORE INJURED UPON OR
AFTER NEXT YEAR A STATE AGENCY
THROUGHOUT THE SOUTH OF MEANT
TO THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET
COMMITTEE INFORMATION REGARDING
THE TERMS AND CONDITIONS OF THE
PROPOSED EXTENSION OR RENEWAL
OF THE CONTRACT THIS BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE OPPORTUNITY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE AND LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT AND TRANSPARENCY
OVER NO BID CONTRACT PRIOR TO
DETERMINE WHETHER TAXPAYER
DOLLARS ARE BEING SPENT IN THE
MOST EFFECTIVE AND EFFICIENT
WAY I THINK EVERY TIME
AFTER I BOTH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THE DOW WOULD MOVE TO
WITNESSES READY TO TESTIFY IN
THIS ROOM ANYBODY WISHING TO
TESTIFY OKAY MODERATOR WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO WHAT THIS IS
WAITING TO TESTIFY THE THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS ANYBODY
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN A FOR IN
SUPPORT OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
PRESS ONE IS THAT THERE'LL AT
THIS TIME ONCE AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT THEIR
WE HAVE KNOWING QUEUED UP FOR
US ALL SEVENTY ONE THANKS VERY
MUCH MODERATOR HAVING HEARD
FROM THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW
FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS IN
HERE FOR MANY OPPOSITION THERE
ANYBODY IN THE ROOM WAITING
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING THAT I WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO WITNESSES WAITING TO TESTIFY
VIA THE TELECONFERENCE ORVIS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB TWELVE SEVENTY
ONE MODERATOR YOU CAN OPEN THE
LINES THANK YOU MISTER TURNER
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
S. E. TWELFTH SEVENTY ONE
PRESS ONE AND THAT THERE
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE FOR SB TWELVE SEVENTY
ONE AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
MODERATOR AND THANKS TO ALL OUR
SUPPORT OPPOSITION WITNESSES
WILL BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS IN THE
BODY WISHING TO ADDRESS
ON THIS BILL CENTER ARCHULETA
YEAH THANK YOU MR I SEE THIS
BILL -- HAS BEEN EFFECTIVE
I'VE SEE IT BRINGING IT BACK
-- IF IT EXCEEDS THAT AMOUNT
TWENTY FIVE MILLION BRINGING IT
BACK TO THE LEGISLATOR WHO WILL
BE ABLE TO VOICE AND INQUIRE
THE THINGS THAT WAS DONE DURING
THE PROCESS WHICH IS DONE
RIGHT WAS ANY VIOLATIONS OF LAW
WE WOULD HAVE OVERSIGHT AND
I THINK BECAUSE OF THOSE ISSUES
THEN I THINK THAT -- BROKER TOM
I CAN GO GO UP ON IT AND MAKE
THE MOTION FOR THANK YOU MR
OKAY THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE
SEEING NONE SIR BECKER WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CENTER WILL THANK
YOU MEMBERS IN FACT COMMENTED
THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SO WHAT WE HAVE -- -- QUORUM
WILL BECOME MOTION IT WILL
TAKE UP CENTER ARTS LETTERS
MOTION AND WILL -- YOU KNOW
THAT THIS POINT I THINK WE'RE
WAITING FOR SENATOR LOAN
IT WILL TAKE A TWO MINUTE BREAK
-- SHARES THE
G. O. -- COMMITTEE WILL
COME BACK TO ORDER -- WE'RE
GONNA MOVED OUT TO YOU --
I ITEM NUMBER TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN CENTER CORTES
C. PLEASE PROCEED
GOOD MORNING SURE IN MEMBERS
I'M PROUD PRESENT SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN A BILL THAT WOULD
PROMOTE ECONOMIC SUCCESS BY
EXPANDING ALCOHOL BEVERAGE
CONSUMPTION RELIEF GIVEN DURING
THE COPA NINETEEN PANDEMIC
QUIETING CRITICAL SAFEGUARDS
FOR CONSUMER SAFETY TO REDUCE
THE SPREAD OF KOBE NINETEEN
AND SUPPORT BUSINESSES IMPACTED
BY THE PANDEMIC THE DEPARTMENT
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE CONTROL
ISSUED REGULATORY RELIEF
FOR OFFICIEL CONSUMPTION OF
ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES UNDER
CERTAIN CIRCUMSTANCES THE
CONVENIENCE AND POPULARITY OF
THIS OFF STILL RELIEF HAS BEEN
ABOUT AS HAS EFFECTIVELY HELP
BUSINESSES SURVIVE THROUGH
AND RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC
INDUCED RECESSION ESPECIALLY
IN A COMMERCIAL PROPERTY WERE
OUTSIDE SQUARES AND WALKWAYS
CONNECT RESTAURANTS SHOPS AND
OFFICES HOWEVER BUSINESSES ARE
STILL STRUGGLING WITH RECOVERING
FROM THE SIGNIFICANT LOSSES
CAUSED BY THE PANDEMIC AS WE
ALL KNOW THAT CONSUMERS AND
BUSINESSES CAN BENEFIT FROM
LIMITED AND CONTROLLED EXPANSION
OF OFF SALE CONSUMPTION IN A
DESIGNATED AREA SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN CAPITALIZE ON THIS
BY AUTHORIZING THE ISSUANCE
OF A CONSUMPTION AREA PERMIT
TO AN ENTITY IN THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE WHO OWNS OPERATES
OR MANAGES A PRIVATELY
OWNED COMMERCIAL AREA THE
CONSUMPTION AREA PERMIT WOULD
ALLOW BUSINESSES TO PROVIDE
A COMFORTABLE ENVIRONMENT TO
ATTRACT CONSUMERS CUSTOMERS WHO
CAN ENJOY ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGES
THROUGH A COMMERCIAL CENTER
WHILE MAINTAINING CUSTOMER
SAFETY USE OF THE PERMIT WOULD
REQUIRE SUBSTANTIAL SAFETY IN
COMPLIANCE MEASURES INCLUDING
JOINT RESPONSIBILITY BY THE
LICENSEES FOR ANY VIOLATIONS
TEMPORARY OR PHYSICAL BARRIERS
AROUND THE PERMITTED AREA IN
SECURITY MEASURES TO PROHIBIT
UNDERAGE DRINKING IN THE AREA
I WANT TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
AND CHAIR OF FOR WORKING WITH
MY OFFICE EXTENSIVELY ON THIS
MEASURE I WOULD ALSO LIKE
TO COMMIT TO TAKING THE TO
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS LISTED
IN THE ANALYSIS -- THOSE
ARE AGREEABLE AND HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF JOHN
BENVENUTO FROM FEDERAL REALTY
IN -- I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
-- OKAY MISTER BENVENUTO
YES I'M HERE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YEAH YES WE CAN I PLEASE HAVE
A SEAT GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE A FEW COMMENTS WITH YOU
THIS MORNING ON SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN ON THE JOHN MANAGER OF
SANTANA ROW -- IF YOU ELEMENT
DOWN DAY -- THIS THIS
BILL WILL ESTABLISH A SMALL
CLEARLY DEFINED CONSUMPTION
ZONES ON OUR PROPERTY THAT
WOULD BE CLOSELY SUPERVISED
BY BOTH SANTANA ROW SECURITY
PERSONNEL IN COLLABORATION
WITH OFF DUTY SAN JOSE
POLICE BARRIERS AND SIGNAGE
WOULD BE PLACED AT ALL ENTRY
AND EXIT POINTS -- AND
-- SIGNAGE WOULD ALSO
BE PART OF THE PROGRAM THAT
EXPLAINS HOW WHERE THE AREA
DEATHS AND WHAT THE RULES AND
REGULATIONS AND PROPER PROTOCOL
ARE AND THE PARTICIPATING
RESTAURANTS ON PROPERTY -- ARE
REQUIRED TO CHECK PATRONS ID
VERIFY AGE UPON PER PURCHASE
AND THEY WILL ALSO BE REQUIRED
TO PROVIDE BRANDED CONTAINERS
-- FOR THE BEVERAGES AND
WRISTBANDS SO PARTICIPANTS
CAN BE EASILY IDENTIFIED
-- IN CASE OF ANY ISSUES
THANK YOU MISS VIDEO LET'S
CONTINUE WITH ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM ANYBODY
WISHING TO SUPPORT ON THIS
BILL -- JEAN DUNN WILL NOW
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
MODERATOR PETER AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
PROMISES FORTY FIFTY FIFTY
FIFTY IN A PRESS ONE AT THE
HI BUT TO GET IF YOU WISH TO
COME IN FOR THE FIFTY FIFTY
FIFTY ONE AND THE THIRD
FIVE SEVENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FROM BOYHOOD
I DO APOLOGIZE ON THE WRONG LINE
THANK YOU THANK YOU
THERE ARE NO GOOD AT THE TIME
OR S. B. FIFTEEN FIFTEEN THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL THE SUPPORTERS
WILL NOW FOLLOW THE SAME PROCESS
IN HERE FROM ANY OPPOSITION I
BELIEVE WE HAVE MICHAEL SKIP BUT
HERE IN THE ROOM IN OPPOSITION
SIR PLEASE PROCEED THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MICHAEL SKIP ON BEHALF
OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE WE ADVOCATE
FOR EVIDENCE BASED POLICIES TO
PROMOTE PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
ALCOHOL HARM HAS BEEN STEADILY
RISING AND ALARMINGLY SO OVER
THE PAST TWENTY YEARS WITH
NEARLY FIFTY PERCENT INCREASES
IN ALCOHOL USE DISORDER
INCLUDING A TEN PERCENT INCREASE
IN FATAL ALCOHOL RELATED
LIVER DISEASES AND A TWENTY
FIVE PERCENT INCREASE IN ALL
ALCOHOL RELATED MORTALITY DURING
COVERT NINETEEN THESE INCREASES
IN HARM HAVE BEEN IN VIRTUAL
LOCKSTEP WITH THE STEADY
LOOSENING OF LONGSTANDING
ALCOHOL CONTROLS INCLUDING
EMERGENCY MEASURES GREATLY
EXPANDING ALCOHOL SERVICE
FOOT PRINTS SIMILAR TO WHAT
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN INTENSE
ALCOHOL LAW INCLUDING BOTH
LIABILITY AND RESPONSIBLE
BEVERAGE SERVICE TRAINING IS
CONTINGENT ON LICENSEES HAVING
THE ABILITY TO OBSERVE AND OR
INTERVENE WITH THEIR PATRONS
BY DILUTING ACCOUNTABILITY AMONG
MANY LICENSEES AND CREATING
AREAS OF CONSUMPTION AND WHICH
NO SINGLE LICENSEE CAN EMPLOY
RBS STRATEGIES SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN MAKES ALL FORMS OF
HAZARDOUS SERVICE MORE LIKELY
INCLUDING CONSUMPTION BY MINORS
WHO ARE NOT RESTRICTED FROM
THE PRESUMED EXPANDED FOOTPRINT
SB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN IS CLEARLY
INTENDED TO GREATLY INCREASE
THE SERVICE CAPACITY OF EVERY
LICENSEE THAT QUALIFIES AS
CONTIGUOUS THIS CONCENTRATES
ALCOHOL CONSUMERS RATHER
THAN DISPERSING THEM AMONG
MULTIPLE VENUES THIS RENDERS
MEANINGLESS ANY PRIOR ASSERTIONS
TO ABC OR LOCAL LICENSING
BODIES AS TO THE EXPECTED
CAPACITY IF EACH LICENSEE
AND THIS GREATLY ENHANCES THE
COMMUNITY SATURATION OF ALCOHOL
ADVERTISING AND BEHAVIORAL
MODELING WHAT IS CLEARLY
ENVISIONED AS AN ALL AGES OPEN
AIR ENVIRONMENT WELL THIS
ONE PARTICULAR LOCATION
IN SAN JOSE MAY NOT VASTLY
EXACERBATE ALCOHOL HARM BY
ITSELF SB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN IS
NOT PROPOSED IN A VACUUM WE
ASK THAT THE COMMITTEE CONSIDER
THE STEADY DISINTEGRATION OF
ALCOHOL CONTROL POLICIES THE
STEADY RISE IN ALCOHOL RELATED
DEATH INJURY DISINTEGRATION
DISEASE AND COST AND RECOGNIZE
THAT DROPS IN A BUCKET ADD UP
TO A DELUGE CALIFORNIA ALREADY
SUFFERS OVER THIRTY FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AN ALCOHOL
RELATED HARM I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON SB THIRTEEN
FIFTEEN THANK YOU THANK YOU MR
SKIPPER I WAS THERE ANYONE ELSE
HERE -- IN THE ROOM -- WISHES
DESPITE OPPOSITION C. NINE
-- MODERATOR WILL NOW MOVE ON
TO THE WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
THANK YOU MR CARE AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO CONTACT IN OPPOSITION OF
FIFTY THIRTEEN FIFTEEN YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ACTORS ON
BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO SOME
OF THE ISSUES THAT EFFECTIVE
FIFTEEN MAY PRESS ONE IN THE TWO
AT THIS TIME WE HAVE NO ONE
IN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY THANKS
AGAIN MY WRITER -- INTO ALL
OUR SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WILL NOW BRING THE
DISCUSSION BACK TO MEMBERS
OKAY THANK YOU SENATOR
GLAZERS SO WHEN WE HAVE A --
A QUORUM CENTER
CORTES SEE WE WILL TAKE THAT
UP ABOUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSER SORRY
NO JUST TO AGAIN THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR A UP EXCELLENT TO
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE TAKEN AND
-- THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP WITH
THAT APPRECIATED THE COMMENTS
FROM THE OPPOSITION ABOUT
-- MAKE SURE THE APPROPRIATE
AUTHORITIES IN THIS CASE
WOULD BE SCPD SELLS A POLICE
DEPARTMENT -- ARE DOING --
CONTINUOUS DATA WORKING STUDY
SAYS POSTED HOW THIS PLAYS OUT
-- -- IF IT SIGNED INTO LAW
SO WE TAKE TAKE THAT SERIOUSLY
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY WE'RE NOW GOING TO
MOVE ON TO -- ITEM EIGHT
THAT'S S. B. ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR WIRE
I'M CHANNELING MY INNER
SENATE MCGUIRE COME ON DOWN
IF
MISTER CHAIR GOOD
MORNING GOOD MORNING
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS I.
COMMITTEE CONSULTANTS AND STAFF
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AT THIS BILL HERE IN
FRONT OF YOU TODAY AND I ALSO
TAKE A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU
TO THE CHAIR THANK YOU TO THE
CONSULTANT TEAM OUT FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND THEIR
GARDEN FOR GUIDANCE SO
LOOK BOTTOM LINE IS CALIFORNIA
MAY CRAFT BEER COOL THE INDUSTRY
IS STILL MOSTLY MOM AND POP THE
INDUSTRY IS MOSTLY INDEPENDENTLY
OWNED AND OPERATED AND CRAFT
BREWERS IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
GROWN SIGNIFICANTLY OVER THE
YEARS I THINK THAT WE CAN
ALL POINT OUT WHICH IS OUR
FAVORITE CRAFT BREWERY IN OUR
DISTRICT BUT ELEVEN HUNDRED
CRAFT BREWERS CALL THE GOLDEN
STATE HOME THE BREWERIES ARE
MORE THAN A NOVELTY YOU'RE PART
OF CALIFORNIANS IDENTITY NOW
THERE ARE COMMUNITIES GATHERING
GROUNDS THE SMALL BUSINESS
OWNERS WHO YOU'LL HEAR FROM
TODAY THEY OPERATE THESE BELOVED
INSTITUTIONS AND THEY'RE OUR
NEIGHBORS IN GOOD TIMES AND
BAD CRAFT BREWERIES HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO THE STATE I COUNTY
FOR ABOUT SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
JOBS AND CONTRIBUTING JUST
UNDER TEN BILLION DOLLARS TO
THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS SINCE THE BEGINNING
OF THIS BELOVED INDUSTRY IN
THE LATE SIXTIES CRAFT BREWERS
HAVE HAD THE ABILITY TO BE
ABLE TO SHIP BEER DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS MOST RECENTLY THIS
ABILITY HAS BEEN A LIFELINE FOR
THE ENTIRE INDUSTRY DURING THE
PANDEMIC SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
IT'S A COMMON SENSE PIECE OF
LEGISLATION THAT WILL MAKE HOME
TOWNS WILL MAKE OUR HOME TOWNS
AND HOME TOWNS IN EVERY CORNER
OF THE STATE STRONGER IT'S GOING
TO PROTECT THE EXISTING ABILITY
FOR CALIFORNIA BREWERS SHIP
BEER DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS BY
EXTENDING THAT SAME PRIVILEGE
TO ADD A STATE BREWERIES TO DO
THE SAME EVEN THOUGH WE MAY NOT
LIKE THAT SO LET ME PROVIDE YOU
A LITTLE BIT OF HISTORY ON THIS
ISSUE BECAUSE IT'S A LITTLE
WONKY WELL CALIFORNIA BREWERIES
HAVE HAD THE PRIVILEGE TO SELL
THEIR BEER DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS
AT THEIR BREWERY BY THE TAP OR
TAKE AWAY THE CALIFORNIA ALCOHOL
BEVERAGE CONTROL ACT DOES NOT
EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZE CALIFORNIA
BREWERS TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS AWAY FROM THE LICENSE
PRINCE THIS IS WHERE THE PROBLEM
LIES IN THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
BILL THE BILL WILL CODIFY THAT
CRAFT BREWERS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SHIP THEIR BEER DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS BUT TO AVOID FEDERAL
CONSTITUTIONAL ISSUES THE
STATE MUST ALLOW OUT OF STATE
BREWERS SHIP IN THE STATE DO I
LIKE THAT NO BUT IT'S THE
LAW IT WOULD BE A CHALLENGE
-- CONSTANTLY CHALLENGE IF WE
DON'T ALLOW THOSE ADDED STATE
BREWERS THE SHIPPING IF WE DON'T
ALLOW THOSE OUT OF STATE BROUGH
RESEARCH SHIP IN THE CALIFORNIA
WILL BE SUSCEPTIBLE TO FEDERAL
LEGAL CHALLENGES LIKE IT OR
NOT CALIFORNIA MUST EXTEND
THAT SAME OPPORTUNITY TO ADD A
STATE BREWERS AND IT'S CALLED
THE DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE
WHICH PROHIBITS STATES FROM
DISCRIMINATED AGAINST OUT OF
STATE BUSINESSES BY THE WAY
THIS IS THE SAME PRIVILEGE
THE LEGISLATURE GRANTED THE
WINE INDUSTRY FOR IN STATE
AND OUT OF STATE WINERIES THIS
HAPPENED BACK IN TWO THOUSAND
FIVE IN THERE IS BLACK AND
WHITE PRECEDENT FOR THIS AND
AGAIN THE WAY BUSINESSES THRIVE
AS WE ALL KNOW IS CERTAINTY
THIS PROVIDES THE CERTAINTY THAT
IS NEEDED TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
THIS SIXTY SIX THOUSAND EMPLOYEE
JOB EMPLOYEE INDUSTRY STRONG
TO CONTINUE TO EXPAND DIRECT
TO CONSUMER SHIPPING IS A LOT
PROPERLY TO KEEP MANUFACTURING
THE LOCAL BEERS THAT WE LOVE
EVEN IN THE DEPTHS OF THE MOST
CHALLENGING TIMES DURING THE
PANDEMIC AND CALIFORNIA BREWERS
CAN'T LOSE THIS LIFELINE SO
I'M GONNA WALK THROUGH WHAT THE
HELL THIS BILL DOES AND WHAT
-- REQUIRED ANYONE WHO USES
THE FRAMEWORK OF THE BILL AS
IN OUT OF STATE PERMIT HOLDER
SO IF I'M SHIPPING FROM NEW
YORK ALL RIGHT FOR MY BREWERY
IN NEW YORK HERE'S WHAT I'M
GONNA HAVE TO COMPLY WITH THIS
BILL AND IT'S ALL RIGHT TO HAVE
THE SERGEANTS BE ABLE TO BRING
THE -- THE POSTER OVER JUST
A BIT BECAUSE WE'RE GONNA POINT
RIGHT TO IT SO NUMBER ONE THIS
BILL WOULD REQUIRE CONTAINERS
TO BE LABELED ALONG WITH THE
MANDATORY SIGNATURE BY PERSON
OVER TWENTY ONE UPON DELIVERY
NUMBER TWO EIGHT MANDATES ADDED
STATE PERMIT HOLDERS MICHAEL IS
IT OKAY IF WE BRING IT ALL THE
WAY OVER THERE OKAY THANK YOU
FOR MANDATE OUT A STATE PERMIT
HOLDERS COLLECTOR IN THAT ALL
SALES AND USE TAXES AND EXCISE
TAXES ON SALES TO RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA UNDER THEIR DIRECT
BEER PERMIT NUMBER THREE IT
REQUIRES THAT PERMIT OFFICE
HOLDERS MUST DEMONSTRATE FULL
COMPLIANCE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
BEVERAGE RECYCLING LITTER
REDUCTION ACT NUMBER FOUR
REQUIRES A PERMIT HOLDERS MUST
REPORT ANNUALLY TO THE STATE
AND AUTHORIZED THE DEPARTMENT
TO PERFORM AUDITS OF PERMIT
HOLDERS NUMBER FIVE AUTHORIZES
THE DEPARTMENT OF ABC TO ENFORCE
THE REQUIREMENTS OF THE BILL
BY ADMINISTRATIVE PROCEEDINGS
TO SUSPEND OR REVOKE THE BEER
DIRECTION PER PERMIT IF THIS
ADDED STATE SHIPPER AND BREWER
VIOLATES CALIFORNIA LAW THE BILL
ALSO OUTLINES BRINGING ALCOHOL
INTO THE STATE WITHOUT A PERMIT
SO THAT IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
YEAH SOME OF YOU MAY HAVE HEARD
FROM OPPOSITION AND I GET IT
ABOUT SOME OF THE CLAIMS AND
I WANNA CORRECT THE RECORD ON
THIS BILL SO WE'VE HEARD A COULD
CLAIM THAT THIS BILL JEOPARDIZES
CALIFORNIA JOBS AND RETAILERS
-- BUT THIS COULDN'T BE
FURTHER FROM THE TRUTH I THINK
THAT'S A BIT MARC SOMEONE
AT TALK ABOUT CALIFORNIA BREWERS
SO FIRST OF ALL CALIFORNIA
BREWERS CAN SHIP TODAY IN STATE
BUT THE VAST VAST MAJORITY
THE PIER THE BEER THAT IS
PURCHASED BY CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS NOT BEING SHIPPED
I IT IS BEING DISTRIBUTED AND
DELIVERED TO BARS RESTAURANTS
GROCERY STORES IN FACT IT'S
ESTIMATED IN THE HIGH NINETY
PERCENT RANGE AT THE HEIGHT
NINETY PERCENT OF ALL BEER THAT
IS AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS IN
THE STATE IS PROUDLY IT'S
PROBABLY DELIVERED BY WOMEN AND
MEN REPRESENTED BY CALIFORNIA
LABOR GOING TO RESTAURANTS
GOING TO BARS IS WELL AS RETAIL
NUMBER TWO AT THE STATE
BREWERIES WHO TAKE THE RISK
TO PARTICIPATE ARE NOT GONNA
BE COMPETING WITH THE JOBS
AND DISTRIBUTION OR RETAIL
ACROSS THE STATE BECAUSE IT
SIMPLY COST TOO MUCH TO SHIP
DIRECT TO CONSUMERS AND THIS
IS WHERE THIS CHART COMES IN SO
I'M GONNA START FROM THE FAR
RIGHT AND WORK OUR WAY TO
THE LEFT SO LET'S FIRST TAKE
LEGACY BREWING IT'S AN IPA
OUT OF NEW YORK SO RIGHT NOW
IF I AM THE BREWERY AT
A NEW YORK I AND
I WANT TO SHIP SEVEN DAYS IT'S
GOING TO COST THE CONSUMER
THIRTY FIVE BUCKS THIRTY FIVE
SIXTY TWO FOR HOW MUCH BEER
FOR SIX PACK THANK YOU FOR A
SIX PACK NOW IF I GO TO SAFEWAY
ON NINETEENTH IN
SACRAMENTO THAT THERE IS
GOING TO COST EIGHT DOLLARS
AND FORTY NINE CENTS TODAY
NOW ILLINOIS' LET'S
GO TO GO SILENT COMING OUT
ILLINOIS RIGHT NOW IF I GO
TO SAY FOUR NINETEENTH STREET
IT'S SEVEN DOLLARS AND SEVENTY
NINE CENTS TO GET A SIX PACK
THAT SIX PACK PROUDLY
PROUDLY DISTRIBUTED DELIVERED
TO THE STORE BY UNION LABOR
AND IT'S SEVEN DOLLARS
AND SEVENTY NINE CENTS NOW
I CAN'T GET SEVEN DAYS I CAN
ONLY GET THREE DAY SHIPPING OUT
OF ILLINOIS IT WOULD BE THIRTY
THREE OH FOUR FOR THE SIX PACK
IF YOU'RE REALLY DESPERATE
FOR GOOSE ISLAND YOU CAN SPEND
TO EARN SIX BUCKS AND GET
IT WITHIN TWENTY FOUR HOURS
I WANNA JUMP THE ORGAN ORGAN
IF I WANT TO GET A SIX PACK
OF THE SHOOT UP WHICH I
KNOW IS CENTER ARCHER LET
HIS FAVORITE -- IN GOES TO
SAFELY RIGHT NOW IT'S TEN
DOLLARS AND NINETY NINE CENTS
FOR TWO DAYS IT'S THIRTY BUCKS
OR SIX PACK THE REASON WHY I
BRING THIS UP IS WHY
THE HELL IF I AM A JOE SITTING
IN VENTURA COUNTY WHAT I SPEND
THIRTY DOLLARS AN EIGHTEEN
CENTS ON A TWO DAY DELIVERY FROM
MORGAN WHEN I CAN GO TO SEVEN
ELEVEN I CAN GO TO CIRCLE K. OR
I CAN GO TO SAFE WAY TO BE ABLE
TO GO BUY A SIX PACK FOR TEN
DOLLARS AND NINETY NINE CENTS
THIS JOB ARGUMENT CANDIDLY
IS FAR FETCHED AND I'M NOT
TRYING TO BE ARGUMENTATIVE
BUT I JUST WANT TO TALK
ABOUT COMMON SENSE HERE TODAY
BOTTOM LINE IS THIS BEER IS
TOO HEAVY TO SHIP BY MAIL TO
EVER BE COMPETITIVE RIGHTFULLY
SO WITH DISTRIBUTORS HERE IN
THE GOLDEN STATE WE'VE ALSO
HEARD THAT THIS BILL CREATES
AN UNREGULATED MARKET THIS
BILL DOESN'T AS I MENTIONED
EARLIER IT REQUIRES OUT OF STATE
PERMIT HOLDERS COMPLY WITH ALL
THE A. B. C. RULES COLLECTING
REMIXED A STATE SALES AND EXCISE
TAXES AND IT OUTLAWS BRINGING
ALCOHOL INTO THE STATE WITHOUT
A PERMIT CREATED BY THE BILL
SO THIS ISSUE WE FACE THAT IT
IS INDISPENSABLE PRIVILEGE THAT
IN STATE BREWERS HAVE TO SHIP
DIRECTLY CALVET CONSUMERS AND
VULNERABLE IT'S VULNERABLE TO
A FEDERAL CONSTITUTION ARGUMENT
IF WE DON'T ALLOW OUT OF STATE
THAT'S THE BOTTOM LINE WE CAN'T
CODIFIED IN STATE SHIPPING
WITHOUT ALLOWING OUT OF STATE
TO COME IN EVEN IF WE DON'T
LIKE IT IF WE COULD I WOULD
SET MY OWN PERSONAL OPINION
THAT'S BLOCK IT BUT IT WOULD
BE CONSTITUTIONALLY A CHALLENGE
AND WE WOULD LOSE I'M GONNA WRAP
IT RIGHT HERE I'M HAPPY
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO THIS BILL
I'VE ASKED FOR AND THEN I'VE
ASKED FOR AMENDMENTS I HAVE
NOT SEEN AMENDMENTS I ASKED
HER NAME IS APPROXIMATELY THREE
THREE AND A HALF WEEKS AGO --
I GET IT THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED
TO THIS BILL DON'T LIKE THE
BILL AND I HEARD THE LINE WE
DON'T MEAN BAD BILLS BUT I
WANNA BE REALLY HONEST AS
LEGISLATORS WE NEED TO HAVE
A BACK AND FORTH AS A NEVER
THIS LOGISTICS WE HAVE TO BE
ABLE TO HAVE A BACK AND FORTH
IN I AM MORE THAN WILLING TO
BE ABLE TO TAKE AMENDMENTS TO
THIS BILL ALRIGHT COMMITTEE TO
YOU RIGHT NOW NONE HAVE BEEN
RECEIVED I'VE BEEN ASKED WOULD
I BE WILLING TO TAKE A COMMON
CARRIER -- AN INMATE YES
BUT THEY HAVEN'T BEEN ASKED FOR
I'M MORE THAN WILLING THIS BILL
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
TEAMSTERS OF THE STATE BECAUSE
THEY DO INCREDIBLE WORK IN BOTH
PUBLIC AND PRIVATE INDUSTRY
AND WE'RE WILLING TO BE A TAKE
AMENDMENTS BUT WE HAVE TO BE
A TO GET THOSE AMENDMENTS FROM
THE OTHER SIDE AND I'M WILLING
TO WORK WITH THE OPPOSITION TO
BE ABLE TO MAKE THIS BILL WORK
OUT WITH ME TODAY MISTER CHAIR
WE HAVE THE AMAZING BEEN ASHBURN
A CO FOUNDER OF CROWNS IN HOT
SPRING COMPANY AS WELL AS KERR
COMMERCIAL FROM ANHEUSER BUSCH
WHO WILL BE SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF THE BILL AND I'M GRATEFUL
TO BE WITH YOU HERE TODAY THANK
YOU SENATOR -- THE STRASBOURG
YOU SEE IT ON THE LOT -- MISSED
THIS CUES MAY SURPRISE WELCOME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR COMING
THIS MORNING OF COURSE THANK YOU
-- GOOD MORNING TO THE CHAIR
AN HONORABLE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE AND I SEE BEER
AFICIONADOS AS WELL -- MY NAME
IS BENNY ASH BURN I'M A CO
FOUNDER AND CEO OF CROWNS
AND HOPS BRING COMPANY WE ARE
THE FIRST BLACK OWNED FEMALE
OWNED AND VETERAN OWNED BEER
BRAND BASED OUT OF INGLEWOOD
CALIFORNIA WE ARE ALSO THE
FIRST BLACK ON VERY TO BE SOLD
AT A SUPER BOWL AT THE RECENT
SO FAR STADIUM WE ARE THE FIRST
BLACK ALREADY BE INVITED TO THE
DISNEYLAND ADVENTURE PARK FOOD
AND WINE FESTIVAL HAPPENING
-- THAT RECENTLY HAPPENED AND
WE ARE ALSO THE FIRST BLACK
OPERATOR RAISE OVER A MILLION
DOLLARS IN EQUITY CROWDFUNDING
SECURING OVER FOURTEEN HUNDRED
PLUS COMMUNITY INVESTORS WERE
NOT ONLY CONSUMERS BUT BRAND
AMBASSADORS OF CROWNS AND
HOPS AS A BRAND WE ARE MAKING
HISTORICAL MILESTONES AND I
CITED BY TIME MAGAZINE WE ARE
CHANGING THE FACE OF BEER I HAVE
NINE THOUSAND PLUS BREWERIES
IN THE UNITED STATES LESS THAN
ONE PERCENT ARE OWNED BY PEOPLE
OF COLOR THAT'S LESS THAN
SIXTY BLACK OWNED BUSINESSES
AND OUT OF THAT SIXTY MAYBE
FOUR ARE OWNED BY BLACK WOMEN
I AM PROOF OF THE NECESSARY
CHANGE THAT WE CAN ACCOMPLISH
IN THE INDUSTRY ONLY WHEN
SUPPORT IS PROVIDED OVER THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS OUR BRAND
HAS BECOME A LEADING VOICE IN
THE BEER INDUSTRY PROMOTING
DIVERSITY AND RACIAL EQUITY OUR
MISSION IS TO REMIND PEOPLE OF
COLOR THAT THEY ARE DESERVING
OF THE VERY BEST PRODUCTS
AND EXPERIENCES BUT TO DO
THAT DIRECT ENGAGEMENT IS KEY
THE W. K. KELLOGG FOUNDATION
STATED BY TWENTY FIFTY OUR
COUNTRY STANDS TO REALIZE AN
EIGHT TRILLION GAIN IN THE GDP
BY CLOSING THE U. S. RACIAL
EQUITY GAP CLOSING THE GAP
MEANS LESSENING AND ULTIMATELY
ELIMINATING DISPARITIES IN
OPPORTUNITY DIFFERENTIALS THAT
LIMIT THE HUMAN POTENTIAL AND
THE ECONOMIC CONTRIBUTIONS
OF PEOPLE OF COLOR WE MUST
TAKE DELIBERATE REALISTIC
AND PROVEN MEASURES TO ENABLE
THE FULL PARTICIPATION OF ALL
IF WE CAN'T REACH OUR CUSTOMERS
THESE COMMUNITIES LOCALLY
AND HOW CAN WE SUCCESSFULLY
PARTICIPATE AND REAP THE
EFFORTS IN THE FRUITS OF OUR
LABORS ARE DIRECT TO CONSUMER
PRIVILEGE IS VITAL TO THE
SUCCESS OF OUR BUSINESS MODEL
AND OUR PERSONAL CONNECTION TO
OUR CUSTOMERS BLACK SPENDING
POWER ALONE IN THE U. S. IS ONE
POINT SIX TRILLION DOLLARS OUR
COMMUNITY HAS ALWAYS BEEN KEY
AND OUR BUSINESS DEVELOPMENT
AND OUR SUCCESS WE DESERVE THE
RIGHT TO BUILD GENERATIONAL
WEALTH FOR OUR FAMILIES AND
WITHIN OUR COMMUNITY WE ARE
ONE OF SO FEW IF WE CANNOT
REACH OUR CUSTOMERS OR ALLOW
THEM TO PATRONIZE THIS HOW
ARE WE EXPECTED TO REALIZE
IMPACTFUL GROWTH ADVANCING
RACIAL EQUITY IS AN INVESTMENT
IN PEOPLE AND ECONOMIC GROWTH
IT REQUIRES THE WORK OF MANY
STAKEHOLDERS AND TODAY YOU ARE
BEING ASKED TO BE CONTRIBUTORS
IN MY CHANGE I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST THAT YOU VOTE YES TO SB
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
FOR ALLOWING ME THE OPPORTUNITY
TO SHOW SUPPORT OF THE ALREADY
EXISTING AND I REPEAT ALREADY
EXISTING PRIVILEGE ALLOWING
BEER MANUFACTURERS TO SHIP
DIRECTLY TO CUSTOMERS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AGAIN I AM
ANY ASPIRIN OF CROWNS AND HOT
SPRING COMPANY THANK YOU THANKS
DECIPHERED FOR SURE YOU BEING
HERE MISTER CAMPBELL CHAU EUROPE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN DOTTING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
THIS MORNING CURT KIMMEL
CHU FRANCHISOR BUSHER THIS
MORNING IN SUPPORT OF SENATOR
MCGUIRE'S SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT AS OUTLINED PREVIOUSLY
BY MY COLLEAGUE MS ASPIRIN
FOR DECADES CALIFORNIA BREWERS
REGARDLESS OF SIZE HAVE BEEN
AFFORDED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SHIP BEER PRODUCED IN THE STATE
DIRECTLY TO THE CONSUMER WHAT
SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT DOES IS
PROVIDE CLARITY FOR CALIFORNIA
BREWERS THAT ARE DIRECT TO
CONSUMER SHIPPING PRIVILEGES
WILL REMAIN INTACT BETWEEN
TWO OF OUR TWELVE FLAGSHIP
BREWERIES LOCATED IN FAIRFIELD
IN LOS ANGELES IN ADDITION TO
OUR GOLDEN ROAD BREWING ASSETS
IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA IN HIGHS
ARE BUSH PRODUCES OVER ONE
HUNDRED DIFFERENT BRANDS HERE
IN THE STATE ALL OF THESE BRANDS
ARE CURRENTLY ELIGIBLE TO BE
SHIPPED DIRECTLY TO CALIFORNIA
CONSUMERS TODAY AND DESPITE
OUR ABILITY TO SHIP DIRECTLY TO
CONSUMERS UNDER CURRENT LAW OUR
DISTRIBUTION WORK FORCE IN THE
STATE HAS NOT BEEN THREATENED
IN FACT IN THE LAST TEN YEARS
OUR WORK FORCE HERE IN THE
STATE HAS GROWN AT A ANHEUSER
BUSCH WE HAVE AN EXTREMELY
STRONG TRADITIONAL ROUTE TO
MARKET COMPRISED PRIMARILY
OF INDEPENDENT WHOLESALERS
FROM ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE
INDEPENDENT WHOLESALERS ARE
SOME OF OUR STRONGEST BUSINESS
PARTNERS AND WE REMAIN DEEPLY
COMMITTED TO UTILIZING OUR
CURRENT DISTRIBUTION NETWORK TO
MARKET OUR PRODUCTS ADDITIONALLY
IN CALIFORNIA WE ARE EXTREMELY
FORTUNATE TO OPERATE SIX
COMPANY OWNED DISTRIBUTION
LOCATIONS THROUGH OUR AB ONE
DISTRIBUTION COMPANY MANY
OF OUR AB ONE EMPLOYEES ARE
TEAMSTER MEMBERS AND WE REMAIN
EXTREMELY COMMITTED TO OUR
TEAMSTER EMPLOYEES NOT ONLY IN
OUR DISTRIBUTION SECTOR HERE
BUT ALSO THE TEAMSTER MEMBERS
THAT REPRESENT THE WORK FORCE
AT OUR BREWERIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY GIVEN ALL OF THIS
YOU MAY BE ASKING WHY THEN IS
ANHEUSER BUSCH SUPPORTING THIS
LEGISLATION BECAUSE WHAT DTC
PRIVILEGES DO IS ALLOW BREWERS
TO INTRODUCE OR SHIP BRANDS
TO NEW CONSUMERS OUTSIDE OF A
BRAND'S TRADITIONAL DISTRIBUTION
FOOTPRINT AND DETERMINE IF
THESE BRANDS ARE DESIRED BY
THE CONSUMERS IF THEY ALL ARE
IT ALLOWS BREWERS TO LOOK AT
SALES DATA SURROUNDING DTC
SALES WITH THEIR WHOLESALERS
AND WORK TOGETHER IN PARTNERSHIP
TO MAKE THEM PART OF THEIR
DISTRIBUTION STRATEGY WHERE
APPROPRIATE MOVING FORWARD
IN THE END THE GROWTH OF
ANY BEER BRAND IS GOING TO
COME FROM THE TRADITIONAL
DISTRIBUTION MODEL THE BREWERS
LIKE ANHEUSER BUSCH INVEST IN
EACH AND EVERY DAY SB ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT DOES NOT UNDERMINE
THE TRADITIONAL WHOLESALER
ROUTE TO MARKET IT SIMPLY
PROTECTS EXISTING PRIVILEGES
THE STATE ALREADY AFFORDS IN
STATE BREWERS AND ALLOWS FOR
ADDITIONAL MARKING OPPORTUNITIES
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA FOR
BRUCE WHO DESIRE A MODEL THAT
WOULD ALLOW THEM ACCESS TO
BOTH DIRECT TO CONSUMER AND
TRADITIONAL DISTRIBUTION MODELS
WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE AND ARE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU FOR
THE TIME THANK YOU MR KIMMEL
SHOE -- LET'S CONTINUE
WITH ANY OTHER WITNESSES
AND SUPPORT IN THE ROOM
A SEEING NONE MODERATOR
-- PLEASE PROMPT INDIVIDUALS
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CARE AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT OR TO THE LEFT IN
NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE INVENTOR OF CATHOLIC ON
BUT AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
THE SUPPORT OF THE ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE THE GENERAL ONE MOMENT
PLEASE BURKE FIRST COME
EXLINE TWENTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HELLO THIS IS LAURIE PORTER --
CO OWNER OF MONKEY BREWING AND
TAKE CARE OF CALIFORNIA CRAFT
BREWERS ASSOCIATION AND YOUR
GET BACK BY SUPPORT CRAPPIE
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT THANK YOU
LIKE TWENTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD HELLO
MY NAME IS LINDA WE BURKE
FOUNDER AND CEO OF THREE
WEAVERS BREWING COMPANY LOCATED
IN INGLEWOOD CALIFORNIA BUT
THEN THE PO COMMITTEE MEMBERS
SENATOR BRADFORD DISTRICT AND
IT TAKES A BIT LONGER DISTRICT
I THINK I PROFIT CENTER I AFTER
YOU MADE THE SUPPORT AT ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
I'VE ALREADY THANK YOU THANK YOU
WHICH IS YOUR NAME YOUR NAME AND
YOUR POSITION PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME YOUR AFFILIATION IN YOUR
POSITION THANK YOU NEXT KALRA
MODERATOR ONE SIXTEEN
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD MY NAME IS
JIM WOOD VIDEO YOUR LINE COMPANY
AND CHAIR OF THE CALIFORNIA
COPPERS ISSUES AND I THANK YOU
LINE EIGHTY YOUR LINE
IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
USUALLY IN CHICAGO -- OWNER
AND BREWMASTER BEACHWOOD
GROWING AND I'M HERE TO
EXPRESS MY SUPPORT FOR THE BILL
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT THANK YOU OUR MODERATOR
AND HAVING HEARD FROM ALL
THE SPORTS NO FOLLOW THE
SAME PROCESS IN HERE FROM THE
OPPOSITION I BELIEVE WE HAVE
MISTER DENNIS LOPER AND MATT
BROAD HERE IN THE ROOM TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION -- THE
-- SUPPORT
TEAM -- IT TOOK A LITTLE BIT AT
A TIME SO I MAY GIVE THE SAME
CONSIDERATION -- FOR FOR THE
OPPOSITION AS WELL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER DENNIS LOOPER FOR
THE CALIFORNIA BEER AND BEVERAGE
DISTRIBUTORS IN OPPOSITION --
WHAT IS THE SENATORS WRITE
HIS BILL CODIFIES EXISTING
PRACTICES THAT HAVE BEEN
GOING ON SINCE THE RELEASE
THE LATE SIXTIES AND WE HAVE
NO PROBLEM WITH THAT WE HAVE
THE PROBLEM WITH THE ONE MAJOR
EXCEPTION AND THAT EXCEPTION
IS TO OPEN OUR MARKETS TO OUT
OF STATE OUR STATE BREWERS
YOU HAVE HEARD THAT THIS
BILL MAY BE DATED BECAUSE
OF GROUND HOME GRANDHOMME
IS A WINE DECISION IT WAS
A WARRANT DECISION BETWEEN
THE STATE OF NEW YORK IN THE
STATE OF MICHIGAN TO PURCHASE
VERSUS HERALD THAT DECISION IS
WITH COULD BE SUBSTANTIALLY
DIFFERENT FOR BARE BEARS
A DIFFERENT PRODUCT IT'S A
PERISHABLE AMONG OTHER THINGS
THIS SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD DECISION
BY THE WAY HAS NEVER BEEN
CHALLENGED IN CALIFORNIA HAS
NEVER HAD A BIGGER CHALLENGE
ANYWHERE IN THE COUNTRY --
IF IF IT WERE TO BE CHALLENGE
IT WOULD BE A LAWSUIT AGAINST
ABC IT WOULD BE UP THE ABC TO TO
DETERMINE THE MULTIPLE REMEDIES
FOR TWO TERMS TO FIX A BILL
WHY SHOULD WE HAVE A CURRENT
PRACTICE IT'S OLDER THAN GRANT
HOME BY MORE THAN TWENTY YEARS
-- NOT CODIFIED ITS EXISTING
PRO PROCESS OR LEFT ALONE
AS IT IS NEVER BEEN A PROBLEM
-- WE ARE INDISCRIMINATELY
OPENING BEARDED MARK MARKETS
TO ANYONE THE ENFORCEMENT OF
GOOD AND BAD ACTORS WILL BE
IMPOSSIBLE -- IF IF A PERSON
DOESN'T GET A PERMIT HOW ARE
YOU GOING TO GO OUT AND AND
WHAT IS A FUNDING CUT MECHANISM
FOR FOR ENFORCING THOSE PERMITS
HOME WE WILL WE BELIEVE
THIS BILL HURTS DISTRIBUTORS
RETAILERS AND POTENTIALLY
CONSUMERS ARE GETTING
BAD PRODUCT WE ASKED FOR
YOU KNOW VOTE AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE MUST A
PURPOSE THANK YOU THANK YOU
THAT'S WHAT GOOD
MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRDS
MATT BROWN ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS -- I THINK
I'M IN THE UNENVIABLE POSITION
OF BEING BACK HERE OPPOSING
ANOTHER ONE OF THESE BILLS THAT
LOOKS IT KIND OF THE THREE TIER
MODEL I I WOULD JUST SAY YOU
KNOW WE RECOGNIZE WE'RE IN KIND
OF A TOUGH PLACE BETWEEN GOOD
TEAMSTER EMPLOYERS -- THAT
THAT SAID ALL RIGHT YOU KNOW I
WANT TO STRESS THAT THIS IS AN
EFFORT TO DEREGULATE IN INDUSTRY
WITH EXTREME UNION DENSITY GOOD
HIGH PAYING JOBS -- FOR THE
TEAMSTERS I WOULD AN ALLERGY
I SORT OF THE THREE TIER MODEL
TO OUR SKILLED AND TRAINED THE
WAY THAT THE BUILDING TRADE
SORT OF TALK ABOUT HOW IT'S A
STATUTORY MODEL THAT PROTECTS
HIGH WAGES UNION DENSITY
AND SO YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THE SENATOR'S
INTENTION AND I I I I DON'T
THINK HE HAS ANY INTENTION TO
SORT OF HARM TEAMSTER JOBS BUT
WE WENT OUT TO OUR LOCALS IN THE
OVERWHELMING CONSENSUS WAS THAT
THIS BILL IS PROBLEMATIC FOR US
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE OPPOSING IT
TODAY AND TODAY TO THE SENATORS
POINT ABOUT AMENDMENTS ON COMMON
CARE WITH EMPLOYEE STATUS I
WOULD URGE HIM TO TAKE THOSE
AMENDMENTS REGARDLESS I THINK
IT WOULD MAKE IT A BETTER BILL
AND WITH THAT I URGE A NO
VOTE ON THE BILL TODAY THANK
YOU THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE
ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY VIA THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS IN OPPOSITION TO
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
SKEWS ME WE HAVE ONE MORE --
-- PERSON WAITING
TO TESTIFY THANK YOU THE
CHAIRMAN JOHN BUT THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU MIKE SKIP
ON BEHALF OF ALCOHOL JUSTICE
ALSO CONSTITUENTS UNDER MCGUIRE
UNFORTUNATELY ARE UNABLE TO --
SUPPORT THIS BILL OR ANY BILL
WHICH WILL INCREASE AVAILABILITY
OF PRODUCT IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NO
VOTE THANK YOU ONE
MORE IN THE IN THE IN THE ROOM
DISTRICTS GO AHEAD -- BRIEFLY MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PRIMARY SUMMIT
APPARATUS BEER DISTRIBUTING
AND R. FOUR THOUSAND EMPLOYEES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF BOTH THE
NORTHERN AND SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
-- RESPECTIVELY OPPOSED THE
BILL AS CURRENTLY DRAFTED
AND -- THANK YOU THANK YOU
MODERATOR NOW WEEKEND -- MOVED
TO THE LINES FOR OPPOSITION
TO SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COME IN OPPOSITION
S. B. ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
THAT'S ONE OF THE GENERAL FUND
AGAIN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION THE BEST ELEVEN
NINETY EIGHT THE PRESS ONE THAT
JEFF ONE MOMENT FOR OUR COMPANY
B. ONE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD
HI RYAN PLAN AGAIN ON BEHALF OF
WIND WHOLESALERS TO CALIFORNIA
AND WERE IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT IN
THE QUEUE FOR OPPOSITION SAFETY
OF OTHER THAN BEING OKAY GREAT
THANK YOU TO ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL NOW
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO OUR
MEMBERS ANY MEMBER WISHING -- TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE SENATOR RUBIO
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- AND
I APPRECIATE ALL THE COMMENTS
AND TESTIMONIALS HERE TODAY BUT
YOU KNOW I HAVE A CONVERSATION
WITH BOTH SIDES THIS MORNING
LABOR AS WELL AS -- THE AUTHOR
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT IS
VERY CLEAR TO ME BASED ON MY
CONVERSATION WITH THE AUTHOR IS
THAT HE IS ABSOLUTELY OPEN TO
TAKING A MEN'S -- BUT YOU KNOW
CONVERSATIONS HAVE TO HAPPEN
AS HE EXPRESS HE'S BEEN TRYING
TO GET THAT FROM THE OTHER
SIDE -- AND I'M VERY CLEAR YOU
KNOW WHAT I LIKE TO SEE AND I
DISCUSSED WITH SOME OF OUR UNION
MEMBERS YOU KNOW THE COMMON
CARRIERS AND AND OTHER ISSUES
THAT I THINK CAN BE A TRUST
AS HE STATED IN AND HE SAID IT
PUBLICLY -- THAT HE'S WILLING
TO SIT DOWN AND HAVE THIS
CONVERSATION NOW IN REGARDS TO
-- THE ISSUE OF OUT OF STATE
I KNOW THAT IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
WHEN WE HAVE THIS CONSTITUTE
CONSTITUTIONAL CHALLENGE I MEAN
AT THIS POINT I THINK ALL OF US
WOULD LIKE TO TO SEE AND STATE
CELLS YOU KNOW DIVIDE IN THIS
CASE I CAN SEE ARE HIS HANDS ARE
TIED -- I'M NOT SURE THERE'S A
CONVERSATION TO BE HAD IF IF --
IF IT'S BEING CHALLENGED IN THE
FUTURE BUT AGAIN FOR ME IT WAS
IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
CONVERSATION CONTINUED IT WAS
IMPORTANT FOR ME TO ENSURE THAT
THE AUTHOR WAS WILLING TO COME
TO THE TABLE AND STATE THAT HE'S
WILLING TO SIT DOWN WITH THE
OPPOSITION TO SEE IF THEY CAN
FIND COMMON GROUND -- WE HEARD
ALSO SUMMIT THE INDUSTRY HOW
THEY'RE COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT THEIR WORK FORCES TAKING
CARE OF AS IT PERTAINS TO THE
TEAMSTERS BUT WHAT I SUGGEST
YOU GENERALLY THERE'S GOOD WILL
ON BOTH SIDES SO IF WE CAN JUST
COME TO THE TABLE AND HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION I THINK THAT WE CAN
GET TO A GOOD PLACE SO BUT WITH
THAT -- I YOU KNOW I WANTED WITH
THE BILL BECAUSE I KNOW THAT THE
AUTHOR HAS YOU KNOW HAD IN DEPTH
CONVERSATIONS WITH ME ABOUT
WHAT HE'S WILLING TO DO AND I
THINK THAT WE CAN GET TO A GOOD
PLACE TO WITH THAT ALMOST FELT
THANK YOU THANK CENTER RUBIO
ANYBODY ELSE WISHING TO ADDRESS
-- OKAY I IS WHAT SORRY
CENTER ALLEN YEAH I JUST WANNA
-- THIS IS A TOPIC THAT WE
YOU KNOW SET THE CHAIR AND I
GOT INTO -- -- EARLY
THIS YEAR IS A LOT OF FUN
-- -- AND OF COURSE YOU
KNOW THE THE THE BEER
ISSUES WHERE IT WORKS TRACKING
FROM THE DOOR FOR A LOT OF
REASONS YOU KNOW I SEE YOU'VE
TAKEN ON THIS ISSUE NOW HAD
ON AND -- I WHILE I'M RUNNING
AROUND LIKE THE REST OF US
IT WAS OVER NATURAL RESOURCES
AS WE'RE TRYING TO DEAL WITH
THE CARBON CAPTURE ISSUES --
HI I JUST WANTED TO SAY THAT
EVERYONE'S COMMENDING YOU ON
YOUR BRILLIANT EXPOSITION OF
THE DORMANT COMMERCE CLAUSE AND
ALL OF THE ISSUES AT PLAY AT
WITH THE FEDERAL JURISPRUDENCE
THAT HAVE MADE IT THIS BILL
SO NECESSARY AND SO I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP
AYE AYE I KNOW WE'RE GOING
TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
PARTNERS IN LABOR -- -- --
BUT -- BUT I DO THINK THAT THIS
BILL WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARD
GETTING THE STATE INTO A GOOD
PLACE WITH FEDERAL LAW AND --
I JUST WANT TO COMMEND YOU FOR
YOUR WORK ON THIS -- SENATOR
AND AND -- CERTAINLY HAPPY
TO MOVE THE BILL OR VOTE FOR
THE BILL I WENT TO PROCREATE
ISRAEL'S OKAY IS CHAIR OF THE
COMMITTEE -- I WANT TO MAKE A
COUPLE POINTS AND YOU I THINK
YOU'VE HEARD THIS BEFORE BUT
I I JUST THINK IT'S IMPORTANT
DIMINISH SOME OF THE CONCERNS
IT'S SOMEHOW SOMEHOW WILL EITHER
HARM THE THREE TIER -- SYSTEM
OR ELIMINATE THE THREE TIER
SYSTEM FIRST OF FORMOSA'S WE'VE
HEARD DURING THE TESTIMONY TODAY
THAT WE YOU ARE IN CALIFORNIA
ALREADY HAS THE ABILITY TO SHIP
UNLIMITED AMOUNTS OF BEER TO
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA THE
DEPARTMENT ABC IS MADE THIS
PERFECTLY CLEAR IN ADDITION BEER
MANUFACTURERS HAVE THE ABILITY
TO SELF DISTRIBUTE MEANING BEER
MANUFACTURERS CAN SELL DELIVER
BEER DIRECTLY TO RETAILERS
WITHOUT THE USE OF AN OUTSIDE
FEAR DISTRIBUTOR BOTH OF THESE
PRIVILEGES HAVE EXISTED FOR
DECADES UPON DECADES IT IS NOT
DESTROYED OR IMPACTED THE THREE
TIER SYSTEM IN ADDITION THE
WINE INDUSTRY HAS HAD THE SAME
EXACT PRIVILEGE FOR SEVENTEEN
YEARS AND -- I IMPLORE ANYBODY
SHOW EVIDENCE IS TO SOMEHOW
HURT ANYONE IN THE ALCOHOL
INDUSTRY INCLUDING DISTRIBUTORS
OR THEIR WORKERS SENATE MCGUIRE
I'M HAPPY TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE IT OUT I JUST WANNA TAKE
A MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU --
YOU AND ALLOW CENTER ALLEN --
YOU KNOW HAD SOME SIMILAR BUT
DIFFERENT BUT SIMILAR -- IN
DISCUSSIONS AND CONVERSATIONS
OVER THE PAST MANY MONTHS I
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO TEAR
DODD FOR HIS SINCERE ENGAGEMENT
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS IN BEING
COMPLETELY TRANSPARENT ON ANY
CONCERNS PLUS -- WHERE HE'D
LIKE IT TO BE ABLE TO GO ON
THIS I JUST LIKE TO BE A CLOSE
ON A QUESTION FROM A MEMBER IF
IT'S ALRIGHT IN REGARDS TO HOW
ENFORCEMENT WOULD WORK AGAIN
WE HAVE A COLD BEVERAGE CONTROL
IN THE STATE THEY GO AFTER
ANY ON PERMITTED UNLICENSED
BUSINESSES ASSOCIATE WITH
SELLING OF ALCOHOL WHETHER IT IS
IN STATE FOR ENFORCING
FOLKS COMING IN FROM OUT OF
STATE HI AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS CREATE PARITY ON ALL LEVELS
FOR REDEMPTION PERMITTING
LICENSING AS WELL AS FUNDS SO
IT WOULD BE ABC THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO OVERSEE ANYONE
IN STATE PLUS AT THE STATE
OF IOWA ALL AND IT RIGHT HERE
AND SAY THIS THANK YOU
THIS TRULY IS ABOUT OUR HOME
TOWNS ABOUT SIXTY SIX THOUSAND
FOLKS IN THE STATE WHO RELY ON
CRACKERS CRAPPER RES ARE
ARE GATHERING GROUNDS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES AND I COMMIT TO
EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU WE
WILL CONTINUE TO ENGAGE WITH
THOSE WHO MAY BE OPPOSED AND
I WOULD JUST SAY THAT I WE LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING AMENDMENTS
AND WORKING THROUGH THESE ISSUES
AND I ALSO WANTED TO THANK YOU
MR LOW BURN MR BROAD FOR THE
SINCERE ENGAGEMENT -- LEADING
UP INTO THIS HEARING WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU CENTER MCGUIRE
SERVICE WE'RE LOOKING FOR ONE
MORE MEMBER OF THIS COMMITTEE
AND WILL HAVE A QUORUM BUT -- IT
TILL WE HAVE A QUORUM -- WILL BE
TAKING THIS UP -- WHAT WHEN THAT
HAPPENS THE FUTURE I JUST WANT
TO SAY THIS CHART HERE MAKES
ME FEEL LIKE WE'RE IN CONGRESS
I JUST WANNA COMMEND YOU
MAKES US ALL FEEL REALLY GOOD
IT TAX IT'S
AN UPGRADE TOTAL UPGRADE
SO -- WHAT NUMBERS
I ITEM FOURTEEN YEAH
FLORIDA SENATOR DOLLY I
KNOW THAT YOU THAT'S S.
B. THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
CHIU CHAIRMAN I'M HERE
PRESENTING S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT DECLARING A STATE OF
EMERGENCY WHICH IS AN IMPORTANT
TOOL USED BY GOVERNMENT LOCALLY
AND STATEWIDE THAT ENSURES
RESOURCES ARE BROUGHT FORWARD
TO ASSIST IN ADDRESSING THAT
EMERGENCY IN MY DISTRICT
IT'S NOT UNCOMMON FOR LOCAL
OFFICIALS TO DECLARE A STATE
OF EMERGENCY WHEN A WILD FIRE
HAS DEVASTATED THEIR COMMUNITY
RESOURCE RESOURCES ARE SOUGHT
AND PROVIDED FOR INCLUDING FOOD
WATER HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE
AND OTHER NECESSITIES OF LIFE
STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL LOOK
AT THE STATE AND FEDERAL LEVEL
REQUESTS ARE THEN ISSUED IF
THOSE COMMITTEES ARE UNABLE TO
PROVIDE THOSE RESOURCES WITH
ONGOING STATE OF EMERGENCY
FOR COVERED THE LEGISLATURE'S
GIVEN THEIR DISCUSSION MAKING
AUTHORITY TO THE GOVERNOR
FOR THE LEGISLATIVE MEMBERS
THOUGHT WHICH THE GOVERNOR
DID WHICH WE THOUGHT WOULD
BE GOOD FOR ABOUT TWO
WEEKS TO BEND THE CURVE
THAT HOWEVER TURNED INTO
TWO YEARS WITH BILLIONS OF
TAXPAYER DOLLARS SPENT BY
THE ADMINISTRATION WITHOUT
ANY LEGISLATIVE INPUT AND
OVERSIGHT SB THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SIMPLE SIMPLY SAYS
IF A STATE OF EMERGENCY
DECLARED THEN CONTINUING
THAT EMERGENCY DECLARATION
WOULD NEED THE LEGISLATURE'S
APPROVAL AFTER FORTY FIVE DAYS
THIS WILL ALLOW THE THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT TO
WORK IN HARMONY TO ADDRESS
THE NEEDS OF OUR RESIDENTS
THROUGH THE COOPERATIVE EFFORT
AND NOT A CONFRONTATIONAL AND
DAVINDER WE HAVE
HAD UNELECTED OFFICIALS
BUREAUCRATS TELLING CALIFORNIA'S
END BUSINESS COMMUNITIES
WHAT THEY CAN AND CANNOT DO
THIS GOVERNOR HAS APPROVED NO
BID CONTRACTS COSTING TAXPAYERS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS WITH NO
OVERSIGHT BY THE LEGISLATURE
THIS TIME THAT THE THAT WE PUT
THE LEGISLATURE BACK IN THE
EQUATION AS AN EQUAL BRANCH OF
GOVERNMENT CALIFORNIANS DESERVE
THEIR ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES
ALL OF THEM TO MAKE THE
DECISIONS NECESSARY TO KEEP
THEM SAFE I ASKED FOR MY VOTE
THANK YOU CENTER GOLLY
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE ROOM
SEEING THAT COMING FORWARD
I WILL MOVE ON TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR RISK MODERATOR
COULD YOU PLEASE PROP THOSE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT THE SUPPORT OF SB
FIFTEEN FIFTY EIGHT EIGHT PRESS
ONE AT THE GENERAL AT THIS
TIME BUT THE GET IT THE
FIRST TO COMMENT SB FIFTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT DEMOCRATS WANT
THEIR ONE MOMENT FOR FROM
HE FEELS
WE'RE STILL GATHERING THE
LINE NUMBER ONE MOMENT PLEASE
FOR TWENTY SEVENTY TWO YOUR
LINE IS OPEN FISCAL HAVE
FIVE SEVENTY TWO YOUR LINE
IS OPEN HE MAY BE A NEW
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK
YOU MY NAME IS JEANETTE AND
I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND WE HAVE NO FURTHER
OKAY THANK YOU MODERATOR HAVING
HEARD FROM THE SPORES ENOUGH
ALL THE SAME -- PROCESS AND
HEAR FROM ANY OPPOSITION ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM WHO
WANT TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE -- MODERATE CAN
WE GO THROUGH THE SAME PROCESS
FOR THE TELECONFERENCE LINE
PLEASE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB THIRTY SIXTY EIGHT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AT THE THEATER
BUT THE GET YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION OF FIFTY THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AND THE GIRL AT THE FRONT
NO COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION OF SB
THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK MODERATOR
-- WILL NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO OUR MEMBERS TO ANY
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS PLEASE PROCEED SUTTER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
CENTER DOLLY I WANT TO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD -- YOU KNOW WE HAVE
MADE SEVERAL EFFORTS TO
BRING THIS TO A CLOSE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LEGISLATURE HOLDS
ITS RIGHTFUL POSITION WITHIN
THE -- GOVERNMENT A STATE OF
CALIFORNIA MAKING DECISIONS
WE'VE NOT BEEN ABLE TO DO THAT
-- SUCCESSFULLY BUT I THINK
IT MAKES PERFECT SENSE THAT IF
A STATE OF EMERGENCY IS DECLARED
WHICH WE ALL WOULD AGREE THAT
WHEN THIS FIRST TOOK PLACE NO
WHEN IT WAS OPPOSED TO MAKING
SURE PEOPLE STAYED SAFE HOWEVER
WHEN IT GOES SO FAR BEYOND
THE SCOPE OF WHAT WAS ORIGINALLY
INTENDED THEN I THINK THE
LEGISLATURE NEEDS TO REIN IT IN
AND SO FOR THE GOVERNOR TO HAVE
TO COME BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE
AND SAY LOOK I STILL THINK THE
CONDITIONS EXIST THAT WE NEED TO
CONTINUE STATE OF EMERGENCY AND
LAY THAT PLAN OUT AND ALL OF THE
REASONS WHY THEN THE LEGISLATURE
CAN CONTEMPLATE THAT AND SAY YOU
KNOW WE AGREE WITH THAT WE WILL
CONTINUE THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
OR WE DISAGREE AND WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO CHANGE HOW THINGS ARE
DONE THAT'S APPROPRIATE THAT'S
WHAT THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA
DESERVE AND WANT AND I THINK
THAT THIS BILL -- IT SHOULD
HAVE THE SUPPORT OF EVERY
MEMBER HERE BECAUSE I WOULD
IMAGINE THAT EVERY MEMBER AND
THIS COMMITTEE WOULD AGREE THAT
THE LOOK THE LEGISLATURE THE
SENATE YOU SIMPLY SHOULD NOT BE
SUBORDINATING THEMSELVES TO THE
GOVERNOR AND WE SHOULD NOT BE
ABDICATING OUR RESPONSIBILITIES
WE SHOULD TAKE OUR RIGHTFUL
PLACE AT THE TABLE THERE ARE
THREE BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT WE
NEED TO REMEMBER THAT AND I A
-- WOULD MOVE THE BILL THANK YOU
ANYBODY ELSE
-- SEE NONE --
THE SERVER DOLLY THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD YOUR
FRANKLY AS I LOOK AT THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S UNNECESSARY IN MAY
HINDER FUTURE EMERGENCY RESPONSE
ACTIONS AS WE POINTED OUT --
THE LEGISLATURE CURRENTLY HAS
BEEN COLD -- HAS CLEAR AUTHORITY
TO TERMINATE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY BUNKER BY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION WE CONSIDER THAT JUST
-- EARLIER THIS YEAR WHEN WE
HEARD S. C. R. -- FIVE BUT
CENTER MELENDEZ IN COMMITTEE
THE I THINK THE BILL ADDS
AN UNNECESSARY BURDEN ON THE
LEGISLATURE DURING AN EMERGENCY
AS WE ALL KNOW EMERGENCIES ARE
UNPREDICTABLE IN THE EMERGENCY
SERVICES ACT IS INTENDED TO
ALLOW FOR A QUICK AND EFFECTIVE
RESPONSE WHEN NEEDED TO PROTECT
LIFE AND PROPERTY I BELIEVE THIS
BILL WOULD DO THE OPPOSITE AND
I'LL BE VOTING NO ON THIS BILL
TODAY CENTER WHICH I CLOSE YES
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS -- BUT I
WOULD JUST I WOULD JUST LIKE TO
POINT OUT THE FACTS THE FACTS
ARE THAT WE HAVE A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AS A TOOL I TOLD
ACTUALLY DRESS OF A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND HERE WE ARE
TWO YEARS ELESSAR WE ALL
TOOK AN OATH TO UPHOLD THE
CONSTITUTION ACTUALLY WE TOOK AN
OATH TO REPRESENT OUR PEOPLE A
MILLION PEOPLE ALMOST EACH ONE
OF US REPRESENT A MILLION PEOPLE
AND FOR THE LAST TWO YEARS
THE I VOTED TO
PUT IT INTO A STATE OF EMERGENCY
BECAUSE WE TOLD THIRTY FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE ARE GONNA DIE
IN AMERICA AND THAT WE THERE
ARE A LOT OF THINGS WERE TOLD
HIM AND WHERE WE ARE NOW TWO
YEARS INTO IT AND WE'RE STILL
UNDER STATE OF EMERGENCY TODAY
THE GOVERNOR LEFT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA ON VACATION FOR TWO
WEEKS UNDER A STATE OF EMERGENCY
ARE WE REALLY IN A STATE OF
EMERGENCY AND THIS LEGISLATURE
REFUSES TO TAKE BACK OUR POWER
I MEAN REALLY TWO
YEARS THAT'S A LONG TIME
PRESSER AT THIS BILL WOULD
BE PRUDENT BECAUSE IT GIVES
US FORTY FIVE DAYS AFTER FOUR
DAYS WE WOULD LOOK AND SEE
IF THE IF WE NEED TO DO OUR JOB
WE NEED TO CONTINUE THE STATE
ORIGINALLY JUST CONTINUING
IF NOT WE COULD THEN START
MAYBE REPRESENTING OUT THE
MILLION PEOPLE THAT WE ALL
REPRESENT AND DO OUR JOBS AND SO
I KNOW THE FIREFIGHTERS HAVE OR
BE THAT THEY HAVE SOME CONCERN
WITH IT AND AND I SAW THEIR
OPPOSITION TO IT WE CAN TURN A
BILL AROUND IN THIS HOUSE IN
IN SEVENTY TWO HOURS SEVENTY
TWO HOURS ALTHOUGH LAW REQUIRES
PRESS TO TURN A BILL AROUND IN
THIS HOUSE AND GET IT TO THE
GOVERNOR'S DESK SO I'M JUST
I'M JUST GONNA GO ON RECORD TO
SAY YOU KNOW MY SELF AND
I KNOW THAT THE -- THE CENTER
MELENDEZ WHO HAD S. R. FIVE WE
WANT TO DO OUR JOB AND WE WANT
CALIFORNIA TO BE REPRESENTED
AS EQUAL BRANCH OF GOVERNMENT
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU CENTER
DOLLY -- WE STILL DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM SO WE'LL TAKE
THIS UP WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
APPRECIATE YOUR TIMES THANK YOU
IS IT WE'RE GONNA LIMóN
SO WE MOVED OUT TO FILE
ITEM SIX -- S. B. TEN
THIRTY BY SENATOR LEE BOTH
TAKE A BREATH
YEAH THE FIRST TAB
THANK YOU TURN MEMBERS SB TEN
THIRTY AUTHORIZES THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO REGULATE ALL
INTERSTATE PIPELINES NOT JUST
THOSE OPERATED AT A HIGHER
PRESSURE CURRENTLY FOR HIGH
PRESSURE PIPELINES THE STATE
FARM AFRICAN REQUEST INFORMATION
REGARDING ACCIDENT REPORTING IN
DESIGN CONSTRUCTION OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE THEY CAN ENTER
AND INSPECT THE RECORDS AND
PROPERTIES OF PIPELINE OPERATORS
TO DETERMINE COMPLIANCE THE
STATE FIRE MARSHAL DOES NOT HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO DO THIS FOR
INTERSTATE PIPELINES OPERATED
AT LOW PRESSURE OVERSIGHT IS
VITAL FOR PREVENTING OIL SPILLS
OIL SPILLS HAVE DEVASTATING
CONSEQUENCES ON OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ENVIRONMENT MORE RECENTLY
IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF GALLONS OF CRUDE
OIL WERE SPILLED IN HUNTINGTON
BEACH THE PIPELINE WAS OPERATED
AT LOW PRESSURE MAKING IT
HARDER TO DETECT A CHANGE IN
PRESSURE THAT WOULD INDICATE A
SPELL BY AUTHORIZING THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL TO REGULATE ALL
INTERSTATE PIPELINES WE CAN
PREVENT FUTURE OIL SPILLS --
REDUCE THEIR SEVERITY IF THEY DO
OCCUR AT TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL TODAY WE HAVE CODY
PHILLIPS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL KEEPERS ALLIANCE
ANIMALS OR MERA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS
MISTER PHILLIPS YOU WANT
OTHER YOUR WELCOME GIFT
HI MY NAME IS CODY PHILLIPS
ON THE POLICY ANALYST FOR
CALIFORNIA GOES DEEPER ALLIANCE
AND I'M HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN THIRTY AS YOU OFFER
DESCRIBED SB TEN THIRTY GIVES
THE STATE FIRE MARSHAL THE
POWER TO REGULATE ALL INTRASTATE
PIPELINES CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC
RELATIONS ARE MUCH STRONGER
THAN THE FEDERAL REGULATIONS BUT
THE OTHER CALIFORNIA PIPELINE
SAFETY ACT AS CURRENTLY WRITTEN
PROVIDES A LOOPHOLE TO OIL
COMPANIES THAT ALLOWS THEM TO
AVOID APPROPRIATE SAFEGUARDS
AND OVERSIGHT BY OPENING
SORRY ABOUT OPERATING THEIR
INTERSTATE PIPELINES BELOW
THE PRESSURE THRESHOLD THESE
OPERATORS AVOID CALIFORNIA'S
HIGHER STANDARDS FOR OPERATION
AND SAFETY WHEN PIPELINES ARE
NOT HELD TO THE HIGHER STANDARD
-- OIL SPILLS ARE FAR MORE
LIKELY TO OCCUR THESE BILLS CAN
CAUSE A SEVERE AND PERMANENT
HARM TO HUMANS -- THE FIX CAN
BE GROUPED INTO RESPIRATORY
DAMAGE LIVER DAMAGE DECREASED
IMMUNITY INCREASED RISK OF
CANCER REPRODUCTIVE DAMAGE AND
HIGHER LEVELS OF SOME TOXINS
THE SCHOOLS ARE ALSO HARMFUL TO
WILDLIFE AND THE ENVIRONMENT AS
A RESULT OF THE TWENTY TWENTY
ONE SPILL -- REFERENCE BY
SENATOR THEM ON THE UC DAVIS OR
-- OILED WILDLIFE CARE NETWORK
FOUND EIGHTY TWO DEAD BIRDS AND
SIX DEAD MAMMALS INCLUDING ABOUT
MOST OFTEN AND THREE CALIFORNIA
SEA LIONS AND UNFORTUNATELY
THE ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS ARE
LIKE THE MUCH MORE SEVERE THAN
JUST REPORTED ALL INTERSTATE
PIPELINES SHOULD BE SUBJECT TO
THE SAME OVERSIGHT REGARDLESS
OF THEIR OPERATION PRESSURE
WE CANNOT CONTINUE TO LET OIL
COMPANIES IF THEY COMPLIANCE BY
RUNNING THE PIPELINES AT A LOW
PRESSURE YOU MUST GIVE THE STATE
FIRE MARSHAL AUTHORITY OVER
LOW PRESSURE IN STATE PIPELINES
-- WITH THAT THANK YOU AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE I ON SB TEN
THIRTY THANK YOU MISTER PHILLIPS
TOMORROW WELCOME YOU MAY BEGIN
THANK YOU CHAIRED MEMBERS
MELISSA ROMERO WITH CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS PLEASED
TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT OF
SB TEN THIRTY WHICH IS AN
IMPORTANT MEASURE TO ENSURE
THAT ALL INTERSTATE PIPELINES
ARE REGULARLY INSPECTED AND
MAINTAINED WELL OIL AND GAS
PRODUCTION CONTINUES IN THE
STATE THE STATE FARM MARSHALL
REGULATES THE SAFETY OF
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED
MILES OF INTERSTATE HAZARDOUS
LIQUID TRANSPORTATION PIPELINES
AND ACTS AS AN AGENT OF THE
FEDERAL OFFICE OF PIPELINE
SAFETY CONCERNING THE X.
INSPECTION OF MORE THAN TWO
THOUSAND MILES OF INTERSTATE
PIPELINES IT DOES NOT MAKE
SENSE TO EXCLUDE ANY PIPELINE
IT'S TRANSPORTING HAZARDOUS
LIQUID SUBSTANCE AND OUR STATE
CORRECT THE REGULAR INSPECTION
AND TESTING AT ALL OF THEM
POSE A RISK TO ENVIRONMENTAL
SAFETY IF THEY'RE NOT PROPERLY
MAINTAINED OUR STATE HISTORY OF
OIL SPILL SPEAK FOR THEMSELVES
AND DEMONSTRATING THIS POINT
FROM THE SANTA BARBARA SPILL
IN NINETEEN SIXTY NINE TO
LAST YEAR'S ARE ORANGE COUNTY
SPILL EACH ONE HAS HAD HAVE
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS ON OUR
NATURAL RESOURCES WILDLIFE
AND ENVIRONMENT THESE EVENTS
CLEARLY DEMONSTRATE THAT
THERE IS NO FAIL SAFE WAY
TO EXTRACT AND TRANSPORT OIL
BUT REGULAR INSPECTIONS AND
PROPER MAINTENANCE OF THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE ARE ESSENTIAL TO
MINIMIZING THE RISK OF FUTURE
SPILLS AS SENATOR LIMóN NOTED
THESE ANNUAL INSPECTIONS ARE NOT
EXCESSIVELY ONEROUS THEREFORE
REQUIRING ALL INTERSTATE
PIPELINES WE REGULATED
REGARDLESS OF OPERATING
PRESSURE IS SENSIBLE FOR BOTH
AN ENVIRONMENTAL AND INDUSTRY
STANDPOINT AND IS CRITICAL FOR
ALL PARTIES TO AVOID DAMAGE
AND LOSSES FROM OIL SPILLS SO
FOR THESE REASONS CALIFORNIA
BERMAN ALL VOTER SUPPORTS SB
TEN THIRTY AND REQUEST YOUR
RIVAL ON THE MEASURE THANK YOU
THANK YOU LET'S CONTINUE
WITH ANY WITNESSES -- IS
THERE ANY OTHER WITNESSES FOR
HERE SEEN DONE A MODERATOR
WILL NOW MOVE TO WITNESSES
WAITING TO TESTIFY VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE OR SERVE SERVICE
IN SUPPORT OF SB TEN THIRTY
I THANK MR CARE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT THAT SPORT ATHLETE
AND THIRTY YOU MAY PRESS
ONE AT THAT ZERO NINE
WHAT BEGAN IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT TO DEPORT SB TEN THIRTY
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE ZERO
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS IN SUPPORT
OF FIFTY TWO THIRTY THANK YOU
MODERATOR HAVING HEARD FROM
THE SUPPORTERS WILL NOW FOLLOW
THE SAME PROCESS HERE FROM
ANY OPPOSITION I BELIEVE PAUL
DARROW IS HERE IN THE ROOM
WAITING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS PAUL DEAR --
REPRESENTING THE WESTERN STATES
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION WISPA
HAS AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON THIS BILL WE DON'T
HAVE ANY PROBLEM WITH WITH
THE SUBSTANCE OF THE BILL OUR
CONCERNS LIE WITH THE HANDLING
AND DISBURSEMENT OF SENSITIVE
PIPELINE INFORMATION POTENTIALLY
COMPROMISING PUBLIC SAFETY
I I I DO COMMIT AND I'M
-- WE'RE LOOKING FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR ON THIS
ON THE THE CONFIDENTIAL NATURE
OF THIS -- INFORMATION THANK YOU
THANK YOU OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION -- CHAIR AND
MEMBERS SHAUN ONE TIME FOR
THE CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT
PETROLEUM ASSOCIATION -- WE
ALIGN OURSELVES WITH THE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THAT
MR DEAR JUST ARTICULATED ON
BEHALF OF WISPA I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO JUST POINT OUT I I
CONTINUE TO HEAR DURING --
-- HE COMMITTEE HEARINGS ABOUT
LAST YEAR'S OIL SPILL IN ORANGE
COUNTY -- THAT PIPELINE WAS
STRUCK BY TWO DIFFERENT ANCHORS
A TANKER SUPERTANKER CARRYING
CRUDE OIL AND A CARGO SHIP IT
WAS STRUCK IN JANUARY OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT BEGAN LEAKING
TEN MONTHS LATER IF THAT CARGO
SHIP OPERATOR AND THAT TANKER
CAPTAIN WOULD HAVE INFORMED THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THE PROPER
AUTHORITIES THAT LEAK WE NEVER
WOULD HAVE HAPPENED SO THIS BILL
REALLY DOESN'T RESOLVE WHAT
HAPPENED LAST YEAR WHAT HAPPENED
LAST YEAR WAS THE FAULT OF
A OF A VESSEL HI IT WASN'T
OPERATOR -- MALFEASANCE IT
WASN'T THEM NOT RESPONDING TO
AN ALARM IT TOOK TEN MONTHS
FOR THAT PIPELINE TO LEAK AND
IF IF THOSE VESSEL OPERATORS
WOULD HAVE INFORMED THE THE
PIPELINE OPERATOR WEEKLY
THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN ENTIRELY
WHAT IT THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY SO WE'RE GONNA MOVED OUT
TO THE -- TELECONFERENCE SERVICE
MODERATOR CAN YOU -- ROB PEOPLE
WAITING TO TESTIFY YOU KNOW
DECISION ON SB TEN THIRTY POLICE
THANK YOU MR CARE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
OPPOSITION OF FE HAS THIRTY
MY PRESS ONE THE GENERAL AT
THIS TIME AGAIN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF FIFTY TEN THIRTY YOU MAY
PRESS ONE IN THE THIRD ROW
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUES IN OPPOSITION THANK
YOU -- THANKS TO OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES WILL
NOW BRING THE DISCUSSION
BACK TO MEMBERS CENTER GLAZER
YET THANK YOU CHAIR DIED --
-- SENATOR I -- WANTED TO GIVE
YOU AN OPPORTUNITY TO ADDRESS
THE CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN
RAISED BY -- ABOUT THE SENSITIVE
AT THE END OF THE INFORMATION
SO WE'RE WORKING BOTH WITH
-- WE SPEND SAID BUT AND CAL
FIGHTER TO ACTUALLY GO THROUGH
THE AMENDMENTS AND TRY TO
IDENTIFY A PLACE WHERE WE HAD
THE STATE HAS THE INFORMATION
THAT THEY NEED -- BUT ALSO
-- CONCERNS ABOUT SAFETY AND
TO I THINK WE'RE NOT THERE YET
IN TERMS OF THE AMENDMENTS THEY
SHARED WITH US -- BUT WE ARE
WORKING THROUGH THIS PROCESS
AT TO MAKE SURE THAT BOTH CAL
FIRE HAS WHAT THEY NEED BUT ALSO
THAT WE PROTECT NOT SENSITIVITY
GREAT COME GLAD TO HEAR THAT
THAT YOU'RE CONTINUING THOSE
CONVERSATIONS AND -- FIVE
YOU HAVE TO FIND THE RIGHT
BALANCE -- OBVIOUSLY YOU'RE
CONCERNED ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND SEEMS THAT THE CONCERNS THAT
THE INDUSTRY HAS -- IS ALIGNED
WITH WHAT YOU WHAT WANT TO DO
AND HOPEFULLY YOU CAN FIND THAT
RIGHT BALANCE APPRECIATE THAT
THANK YOU THANK YOU SEE
NO OTHER MEMBERS -- SECTOR-LIMóN
WHICH I CLOSE THANK YOU CAN I
JUST CLARIFY SOMETHING ELSE THAT
WAS THAT BY THE OPPOSITION IN
NO WAY IS THIS BILL GOING TO
SOLVE WHAT HAPPENED IN ORANGE
COUNTY BUT I THINK THIS THAT
THAT EXAMPLE WAS USED AS A
LOW PRESSURE UP PIPELINE AND
THE EXAMPLE WAS USED AS A REASON
RIGHT WHY WE SHOULD CONTINUE
TO TO UNDERSTAND WHAT HAPPENED
AND WITH THESE PIPELINES SO
YOU KNOW JUST TO BE CLEAR THIS
BILL DOESN'T SOLVE FOR WHAT
HAPPENED THERE BUT IT DOES IT
IS AN EXAMPLE OF LOW PRESSURE
UP HIGH PLAINS AND WHAT CAN
HAPPEN WHEN THEY LEAK SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE THANKS SENATORS
YOU KNOW WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO WE'LL TAKE THIS UP
AS SOON AS WE GET A QUORUM
WE ARE GOING THE WRONG WAY I
MIGHT ADD AND -- WITH TWO
BILLS LEFT THAT -- I THINK ARE
GOING TO BE FAIRLY STREAMLINED
I'D LIKE TO ASK MEMBERS TO
-- GET DOWN HERE SO WE CAN GET
A QUORUM MAY GET THE BUSINESS
OF THIS COMMITTEE -- COMPLETED
SENATOR JOE BLOW
WE'VE GOT YOUR S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE THAT'S ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN WELCOME THANK YOU
I THINK THIS IS MY FIRST
TIME IN THIS COMMITTEE I
IT'S A PLEASURE TO BE HERE
SORRY MISSING MANY OF THE -- THE
MEMBERS MISTER MRS
MISTER CHAIR IMPORTANCE
-- WELL THANK YOU I AM PLEASED
TO PRESENT IN THE BILL THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE STAFFER
WORKING WITH ME ON THIS MEASURE
I WILL BE TAKING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS FOR THE
RECORD SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE WILL CREATE A DESIGNATION
WITHIN THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
BIDDING PROCESS THAT HIGHLIGHTS
CALIFORNIA HEADQUARTERED
COMPANIES AS WELL AS COMPANIES
THAT ARE HEADQUARTERED ELSEWHERE
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT STILL
MANUFACTURE THEIR GOODS IN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
WIELDS THE POWER TO AWARD PUBLIC
CONTRACTS FOR A VARIETY OF GOODS
AND SERVICES WITHOUT THE NORMAL
COMPETITIVE BIDDING PROCESS
MANY CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURING
COMPANIES OFTEN LOSE OUT ON THE
SPIT IN FAVOR OF LARGE SCALE
INTERNATIONAL COMPANIES WHO
CAN AFFORD TO QUICKLY PRODUCE
GOODS TO SCALE AT A BELOW MARKET
RATE GIVEN THE CALIFORNIA HAS
A VAST NUMBER OF MANUFACTURERS
SPANNING VARIOUS INDUSTRIES IN
THE STATE THIS BILL PROVIDES THE
STATE WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
IDENTIFY BUSINESSES AND JOBS
IN CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S
TWENTY TWENTY ONE BROKE OUT
BUDGET ALLOCATED NINE HUNDRED
AND TWENTY MILLION DOLLARS
FOR MASK ALONE IF THIS MONEY
HAD BEEN ALLOCATED TO A NUMBER
OF CALIFORNIA BASED PP MANY
FACTORS THE STATE WOULD HAVE
INJECTED NEARLY A BILLION
DOLLARS INTO OUR OWN ECONOMY
THIS THIS WOULD HAVE HAD A
RIPPLE EFFECT IN CALIFORNIA'S
ECONOMY STIMULATING BUSINESSES
JOB OPPORTUNITIES AND SUPPORTING
BLUE COLLAR WORKERS IN THE
STATE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
IDENTIFY LOCAL INDUSTRY
WILL ALSO ENCOURAGE FURTHER
TECHNOLOGICAL INNOVATION AS
CALIFORNIA RECOVERS FROM COMING
NINETEEN THE STATE SHOULD
FOCUS ON UPDATING THE ITS
STATE OF EMERGENCY POLICIES
TO PROVIDE SPECIAL -- IDEEN
AB CONSIDERATIONS FOR CALIFORNIA
COMPANIES AS WELL AS THOSE
THAT ARE BASED IN THE UNITED
STATES BUT DO THEIR BUSINESS
PRIMARILY IN CALIFORNIA THIS
BILL PROVIDES THE STATE WITH AN
OPPORTUNITY TO FACILITATE A MORE
BUSINESS FRIENDLY ENVIRONMENT
IN CALIFORNIA HAS CALIFORNIA
CONSIDERS PUBLIC BIDS FROM
COMPANIES WHO ARE HEADQUARTERED
IN CALIFORNIA OR IN THE UNITED
STATES SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE PROVIDES THE STATE WITH THE
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK CONTRACTS
TO THESE COMPANIES IN A WAY
THAT HIGHLIGHTS CALIFORNIAN
INDUSTRY WITHOUT SACRIFICING
QUALITY OR EFFICIENCY IN THE
GOODS PROCUREMENT PROCESS
DURING THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
I WOULD LIKE TO HIGHLIGHT AND
EMPHASIZE THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT AT MANDATE THAT WE USE
CALIFORNIA BASED COMPANIES
BUT AT LEAST IDENTIFIED SO
THAT WE CAN CONSIDER THEM I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I ABOUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
I BELIEVE YOU HAVE JESUS
IN CARDIFF ON THE COASTLINE
YES MISTER CARDIFF IS ON
THE LINE FEEL FREE TO BE A
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I THINK
U. S. SENATOR AND THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN DIED IN THE COMMITTEE
-- MY NAME IS JASON CARTER
I AM THE CO FOUNDER OF EPL
MEDICAL WE ARE PROUD TO SAY
THAT WE ARE ONE OF THE NATION'S
LARGEST REQUIRED MEDICAL MASK
MANUFACTURING COMPANIES WE ARE
LOCATED IN RANCHO CUCAMONGA
CALIFORNIA AND LIMóN PRIOR HE
STARTED HIS COMPANY IN TWENTY
NINETEEN BECAUSE WE FOUND OUT
THAT NOBODY WAS MAKING TO SCALE
B. Y. SURGICAL FACE MASKS
IN THE UNITED STATES I'M A
THIRD GENERATION CALIFORNIANS
WITH VERY PROUD CALIFORNIA
ROOTS IT BECAME EVIDENT TO US
THAT WE NEED TO CLOSE THE LOOP
ON FOREIGN SOURCED SUPPLIES
AND MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
HAD A ROBUST MANUFACTURING
INDUSTRY FOR P. P. AND MEDICAL
SUPPLIES EVEN BEFORE COVERED
BECAME THE TRUE PANDEMIC IT WAS
IT IS A SAD DAY FOR ME
THE STATE TODAY THAT WE
CURRENTLY NOR HAVE WE EVER
HAD THE CONTRACT FROM THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA WHETHER
IT IS AN EMERGENCY OR NOT IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE FOR A COMPANY LIKE
MINDED EMPLOYEES CALIFORNIANS
I WILL SAY OUR FIRST LINE
OF EMPLOYMENT I'M FROM THE
HELPING HANDS PROGRAM THE
EMPLOYEE PRIMARILY THREE
WESLEY INCARCERATED FEMALES
CAN SERVE THEIR TIME IN THE
STATE INSTITUTION AND ARE
WE ENTERING THE WORK FORCE
AND WE ARE NOT ABLE TO GET
A CONTRACT WITH THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA BECAUSE PRIMARILY
AS SENATOR OF TOLD VOGUE HAS
SAID SO ELOQUENTLY AND HER
STAFF IS RESPONSIBLE DILIGENTLY
IT IS VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
A CONTRACT WITH THE MAJORITY
OF THEM ARE GOING OVER SEATS
I AM IN FULL SUPPORT OF S. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE I AM PROUD
TO BE A CALIFORNIAN AND I AM
PROUD TO MANUFACTURE AND BOY
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU THANK YOU
THANK YOU WILL NOW MOVE ON
-- TWO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY THE THE TELECONFERENCE
ORVIS MODERATOR CAN YOU PUT
PROP PEOPLE AT SUPPORTIVE SB
THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE POLICE
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN SUPPORT
OF THE THIRTEENTH TWENTY ONE
REFLECT ON THE ACT OKAY
WITH THE GUESTS WHO WISH TO
COME INTO THE PORT SB THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE IN THE PAST FOR THE
VERO YEAH WE HAVE NO COMMON
THANK YOU FOR THE FIFTY THIRTY
TWENTY ONE THANK YOU HAVING
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WILL
NOW HAVE THE SAME PROCESS FOR
MANY OPPOSITION I SEE NONE
IN THE ROOM MODERATOR CAN YOU
MOVE ON TO WITNESSES WAITING TO
TESTIFY -- IN OPPOSITION TO S.
B. THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CARE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN OPPOSITION SB THIRTEEN THE
ONE YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THAT
ZERO AT THE TIME AGAIN
WHICH DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF FD THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE YOU
MAY PRESS ONE AND THEN THERE'S
I HAVE NO COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION
TO FIFTY THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
THANK YOU MODERATOR -- DO ANY OF
OUR MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS CENTER GLAZER
THANK YOU JERRY DIED AT CENTER
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PASSION
IN THIS AREA WHICH I SHARE --
THE STAFF ANALYSIS RAISES A
QUESTION OF -- WHY WE WOULD
ONLY HAVE THE SUPPLY TO STATES
OF EMERGENCY VERSUS THE REGULAR
COURSE OF BUSINESS FOR THE
STATE COULD YOU ADDRESS THAT
THAT FLAG WHY ONLY DURING THE
GET YOUR BILL ONLY DEALS WITH
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY IS THAT
RIGHT YES AND I THINK THE REASON
WE'D TAKE THAT POSITION OR
REGIONALES BECAUSE HE BECAME A
WHAT WE BECAME AWARE OUR OFFICE
BECAME AWARE OF THE FACT THAT
I'M IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS
DURING THE EMERGENCY SERVICES
-- AB OR THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
THERE WAS NO IDENTIFICATION
-- IN THE APPLICATION PROCESS
THAT ALLOWED US TO SEE WHICH
WAY THE COMPANIES WERE LOCATED
SO WE THOUGHT THAT THAT'S WHERE
THE PRIMARY CONCERN CAME FROM
THAT THAT'S RIGHT STEM FROM WAS
FROM THAT STATE OF EMERGENCY
AND NOT HAVING THE ABILITY TO
IDENTIFY THESE COMPANIES -- I
WOULD BE HAPPY TO EXPLORE AB
YOU KNOW HAVING IN EXTENDING IT
OUTSIDE OF THE THAT SCOPE BUT
THAT THE ORIGINAL INTENT OR THE
CONCERN CAME FROM -- THAT
THAT DECISION PROCESS OR THAT
-- APPLICATION PROCESS I WOULD
SAY THE APPLICATION BECAUSE
WE'RE JUST WE'RE NOT ASKING
THAT THE AB THAT DATE
AT THAT THE BILL'S ON EMPHASIZE
THAT THEY BE PRIORITIZED BUT
AT LEAST IDENTIFIED AND IF
THE POWERS THAT BE FOR SEE IT
FIT WE WOULD LOVE FOR THEM TO
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CHANCE AT RIGHT AND SO IS IT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING THAT IN THE
NORMAL COURSE OF BUSINESS THAT
THAT IDENTIFICATION IS SELF
EVIDENT BY THEIR APPLICATIONS
AND THAT ONLY IN THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY IS THAT NOT SO EVIDENT
AT THE CONCLUSION YOU CAME TO
ALL THE TIME THAT IN THE NORMAL
COURSE OF OF A BIDDING FOR
CONTRACTS AT THE LOCATION OF
THE BETTER IS IS IS EVIDENT
BUT IN THE STATE OF EMERGENCY
IT'S NOT HAPPENING I CAN'T
SAY OTHERWISE BUT I KNOW THAT
THE STATE OF EMERGENCY IS WHAT
OUR PRIORITY WILL BE TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE IDENTIFIED I
AM I'M SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND I THINK THIS
THAT WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT
THE BILL IS IS A GOOD ONE I'M
ONLY AT RAISING THE QUESTION
THE STAFF HAS DONE THAT IT SEEMS
LIKE IF WE WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT -- POSITIVE
THEN WHY WOULD WE CAN APPLY IT
TO TO ALL ALL FITTING THAT
GOES ON THAT'S FINE AND I CAN
I TAKE YOUR COMMENTS IS ONE
IN WHICH YOU MIGHT EXPLORE I
WOULD LOVE TO DO THAT AND IF
NEEDED I WOULD DEFINITELY FOLLOW
THROUGH WITH THAT YEAH HAVE
BEEN MOVED ABILITY PREPARATORY
THANK YOU SIR GLAZER --
OKAY -- ANYBODY ELSE SEEING
NONE -- SEARCH -- BOTH
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AT
UNDERDOG SB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
WILL SIMPLY INCLUDE A MECHANISM
FOR THE SELF IDENTIFICATION OF
A BITTER WHO IS HEADQUARTERED
IN CALIFORNIA HAS A PRINCIPAL
PLACE OF BUSINESS IN CALIFORNIA
AND THOSE WERE HEADQUARTERED
IN THE UNITED STATES BUT
WHO PRIMARILY MANUFACTURE
THEIR GOODS OR PROVIDE THEIR
SERVICES IN CALIFORNIA I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A NIGHT
OUT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS YOU KNOW WE DO NOT HAVE A
QUORUM SO -- WHEN WE HAVE
THAT -- WE WILL PUT THIS TO
A VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WOULD AGAIN I'M CALLING ON
MEMBERS -- THAT WE GET THE LAST
WE GOT THE LAST BILL SENATOR
HERTZBERG IS COMING UP S.
B. FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN COME ON UPSET
HERTZBERG MEMBERS COME
TO THE COMMITTEE ROOM NOW
OKAY OKAY
GREG VERY BRIEFLY -- MISTER
CHAIRMAN A COUPLE OF THINGS
CALIFORNIA UNDER THIS MEASURE SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ALTERNATIVE
CONTRACTING PROCEDURES
CALIFORNIA'S MEMBERS KNOW ON
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
REQUIREMENTS TO ENSURE THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF EXPERIENCE
REQUIRED OF WORKERS TO BUILD
BUDGET PUBLIC PROJECTS THE
RESULT IS A PUBLIC AGENCIES
AND TAXPAYERS RECEIVE THE
HIGHEST QUALITY OF CONSTRUCTION
UNFORTUNATELY DESPITE THESE
CLEAR RULES MEMBERS NOT
ALL CONTRACTORS HERE TO THE
SKILLED AND TRAINED WORKFORCE
LAW THAT IS CURRENTLY THE
LAW IN CALIFORNIA THIS IS
PARTICULARLY TRUE FOR THE
FINISHING CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
WHICH INCLUDES INSULATION
PURCHASE OF CARPETS RESILIENT
FLOORING SYNTHETIC TURF AND
LIGHTING FIXTURES MEMBERS THIS
MEASURE REINFORCES CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE REQUIREMENT FOR THE
FISHING INDUSTRY THUS ENSURING
THE QUALITY CONSTRUCTION OF
PUBLIC WORKS CAN'T CONTINUE
OF PROMOTING QUALITY JOBS MIKE
GREENLEE OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES IS YOURS WITNESSES AS
WELL AS ERIC ESPARZA OF MIKE'S
CONSTRUCTION CUSTOM FLOORING
ACTUALLY YESTERDAY I VOTE
TWO GREENLEE PLEASE PROCEED
-- THAT YOU'RE A MEMBER OF
THE MY NAME IS MIKE GREENLEE
HOW MANY OF POLITICAL DIRECTOR
AND LEAD ORGANIZER FOR THE
PAYER KNOWLEDGE TRADE EVERY
ALL OF CALIFORNIA AND NEVADA
FIFTY FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
THE DEPARTMENT OF GENERAL
SERVICES CAN USE ALTERNATIVE
PROCUREMENT METHODS AND MAKE
THEM AVAILABLE TO LOOK WHAT
YOU CHOOSE HIS MOTHER'S INCLUDE
CONTRACTS CORRECT INVOICES
MASTER AGREEMENTS ALL FORWARD
SCHEDULES COOPERATIVE AGREEMENTS
YOU KNOW THE TYPE OF TYPES
OF AGREEMENTS WITH PRIVATE
SUPPLIERS YOU LEVERAGES STATE
BUYING POWER FOR ACCUSATIONS
OF MATERIALS AND INSTALLATION
SERVICES ALSO WHEN THE ALTERNATE
PROCUREMENT METHODS ARE USED
THE LABOR PORTION CANNOT LOW
ROAD CONTRACTORS USING ARE
HERE TO LAWS AND REGULATIONS
REGARDING PUBLIC WORKS WORKER
PROTECTIONS WITHOUT THE
REQUIREMENT REPORT IN THESE
CONTRACTS CAN BE DIFFICULT
OR IMPOSSIBLE TO MONITOR ANY
SUCH CONTRACT THAT'S A JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT COOPERATION
COMMITTEES WHEN TRYING TO ENSURE
WORKERS ARE BEING PAID CORRECTLY
PROTECTED FROM EXPLOITATION
MANY TIMES WE SUBCONTRACT WE
FIND CONTRACTORS AND THE WARS
THE PROJECT SUBCONTRACTED LABOR
OUT TO EACH YEAR ONE OR TWO
SUB CONTRACTOR MISCLASSIFIED
WORKERS YOU PAY LOWER RATES
FOR CLASS BY THE WORKERS AS
INDEPENDENT CONTRACTORS OR BELOW
THE PREVAILING WAGE RATES THEY
ALSO PAID OFF OKAY PIECE WORK
RATES PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA OUT OF TAX BURDEN
BESIDES VIOLATIONS WHICH ARE
PREVALENT IN THE UNDERGROUND
PARKING HE STOPPED AT THE
FOURTEEN POINT TWO IS A GREAT
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
WHEN IT COMES TO BATTLING SOME
OF THE VIOLATIONS YOUR GALLERY
ALTERNATE CONTRACTING METHODS
REGARDING INSTALLATION OF
CARPET RESILIENT FLOORING THE
DIRECTOR FOR A LIVE PICTURES SB
FOURTEEN POINT TO ENSURE THAT
IT PERCENT OF GRADUATES OF THE
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE USED TO THESE
PRODUCTS AT THESE CONTRACTS ARE
REPORTED TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS FOR BETTER
TRANSPARENCY THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I ASK YOU FOR YOUR
SUPPORT SB FORTUNES WHAT YOU'RE
MISTER SPARS ARE YOU ON
THE COASTLINE AS WELL SIR
-- YOU'RE HERE IN IN THE HOUSE
I'M HERE TO TESTIFY -- IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO -- ERICA'S BARS OF
MY CUSTOM FLOORING I'M ALSO
-- MANAGEMENT TRUSTEE ON THE
TRAINING COMMISSION OR L. U.
TWELVE TWELVE FORTY SORT SEVEN
IN LOS ANGELES -- I BELIEVE
THAT THIS -- BILL WOULD HELP
SOLVE SOME OF THE -- PROBLEMS
IN THE MARKETPLACE CONCERNING
ALTERNATIVE CONTRACTS I GO
TO A LOT OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
ARE MY TEAM BECAUSE A LOT OF
SCHOOL DISTRICTS -- LOOKING
FOR FLOORING NEEDS ASKING PUBLIC
ENTITIES WILL DISTRICTS FOR THE
FLOOR NEEDS AND A LOT OF TIMES
THEY SAY HEY WE'RE ALL RIGHT WE
DON'T NEED ANYTHING WE'RE GOOD
WHICH IS REALLY STRANGE TO ME
THAT A SCHOOL DISTRICT OR A OR
A PUBLIC AGENCY DOESN'T GO OUT
TO BID FOR THREE TO FIVE YEARS
ABOUT FORTY FIFTY PLUS SCHOOLS
I'M NOT GOING OUT TO BID MONEY
ANY FLOORING REPLACEMENT FIVE
YEARS -- WELL THEY'RE USING
ALTERNATIVE CONTRACTING METHODS
-- WHICH IS A GREAT TOOL FOR
THE PUBLIC SECTOR TO -- ENGLAND
BIDDING PROCESS SINGLE SOURCE
PURCHASES AND ALL OBVIOUSLY
CUT CUT SHORT THE TIME IT TAKES
TO GET A PROJECT DONE IN THE
PUBLIC SECTOR HOWEVER THEY'RE
MISSING LANGUAGE -- IN THESE
CONTRACTS WRITTEN REQUIRING --
SKILLED AND TRAINED LABOR ARE
MISSING LANGUAGE CONCERNING --
REGISTERING WITH THE D. I. R.
IN REGARDS TO CPR AND --
PREVAILING WAGE PROVISIONS CELLS
THESE PROVISIONS ARE IMPORTANT
TO ENSURE PUBLIC BUILDINGS
GET TOP QUALITY UPGRADES ALSO
THAT THE EMPLOYEES THAT ARE
WORKING ON THESE BUILDINGS ARE
PAID HER CURRENT CALIFORNIA
STATE LAW REQUIRES REQUIRING
PREVAILING WAGE THANK YOU FOR
YOUR SUPPORT AND CONSIDERATION
IN THIS MATTER BEFORE WE TAKE
ANY OTHER SPEAKERS WE'RE GONNA
BREAK OUT AND GET A QUORUM
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SECTOR
DAUGHTER HERE ARE HERE ALLEN
ALLEN HERE ARCHULETA BACKER
BORJAS BRADFORD GLAZER
LATER HERE WESTELL LEGAL
COME BACK IN HERE WESO HERE
JOHN JONES HERE KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ HERE
PORTANTINO WHAT INTO NO
HERE RUBIO RUBIO PRESENT
FORM OKAY WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
NOW WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE
ON SKEWS THE GENTLEMAN
CAN WE HAVE ORDER HERE
ON SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
THOSE IN SUPPORT PLEASE
PROCEED THERE IN THE ROOM
HERE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
MAP BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU MATT
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS
MIKE WEST ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
GOOD MORNING THAT CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS CHAD SMITH FROM THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
INTERNATIONAL UNION AND I'M
IN SUPPORT OF FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO THANK YOU THANK YOU
GOOD AFTERNOON -- MY NAME
IS ROBERT SMITH AND THE
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES
-- SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
IN A URGE FOR AN AYE
VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
-- WHERE --
RESILIENT FLOORING DECORATIVE
COVERING LOCRIAN TWELVE FORTY
SEVEN WELL WE STAND IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU THANK YOU
OKAY -- MODERATOR IF WE COULD
-- PROMPT INDIVIDUALS WHEN
HE TESTIFIED IN SUPPORT OF
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO PLEASE
THANK YOU MR CARE AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
IN SUPPORT THE FOURTEENTH TWENTY
QUEUE YOU MAY PRESS ONE THE
EURO AT THE TIME BUT TO GET
IN ORDER TO USE YOUR
INSIDE VOICE IS POLICE
I WANT TO GET IF YOU WISH TO
SUPPORT SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO YOU MAY PRESS ONE INVESTOR
WE HAVE NO COMMENT IN THE
QUEUE IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO THANK YOU FOR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- SO WE
MOVED OUT TO THOSE IN OPPOSITION
ANYBODY HERE IN OPPOSITION
SEEING NONE -- WILL MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LIGHTED ANYBODY
THAT'S IN OPPOSITION OF SB
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO MODERATOR
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT IN OPPOSITION
OF SB FOURTEEN TWENTY THREE
THAT'S ONE OF THE GENERAL AT
THIS TIME BUT TO GET TO THIS
DEPARTMENT IN OPPOSITION TO
THAT THE FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWO
YOU MAY PRESS ONE AT THE VERY
NO COMMENTS IN THE QUEUE
IN OPPOSITION OKAY THANK
YOU I DO ANY OF OUR MEMBERS
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS THIS BILL WITH
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
HUESO SUTTER HERTZBERG WHICH
I CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU SO MUCH
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY
TWO BUDGET IS TO PASS
APPROPRIATIONS DODD I THOUGHT I
NIELSEN ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA BECKER FORGES
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE
GLAZER WAS VERY PERSUASIVE
WESO WESEL II JONES
I JONES I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
AT SEVEN ZERO SEVEN SEVEN
DOUBLE BILLS ON CALL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MEMBERS WAS
GERMAN WE GOT A MOTION BY
SENATOR HUESO DO -- MOVE THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SECTOR
PLEASE CALL WILL DOT
ALL RIGHT DOT HI NIELSEN ALLEN
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA BAKER
FORGES BORDERS I BRADFORD
ON THE CONSENT IT'S
BRADFORD AYE GLAZER LATER
I WAS SO WET SO I JONES
I JONES HI KAMLAGER KAMLAGER
I MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
WILK BILL WAS TEN VOTES
-- THAT WILL BE ON CALL
IF SO LET'S BEGIN AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B. NINE
EIGHTY BUT SENATOR WIENER MMHM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL WE KNOW WE
NEED A MOTION SKEWS ME WITH --
THE MOTION -- WE NEED A MOTION
WE NEED A MOTION ON THIS ONE
CENTER HUESO
YOU KNOW IF WE ARE TO HAVE
A MOTION FROM CENTER RUBIO
DOES THAT COUNT SINCE IT WAS
NOBODY TO CENTER HUESO IS
MOVES SECTOR CALL THE ROLL
THIS IS ITEM FIVE SB NINE ET
OKAY FILE ITEM FIVE SB NINE
EIGHTY MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
DODD I THOUGHT I'D NIELSEN
ALLEN ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
BAKER BORDERS BRADFORD
BRADFORD HI GLAZER GLAZER
AYE WESO WEST SO I'D
JONES JONES I KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO
AT SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO
THE BILL'S ON CALL FOR
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO -- S. B.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TEN
THIRTY BY SENATOR LEE MON WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR HUESO
THANK YOU OKAY THIS IS FILE
ITEM SIX SB TEN THIRTY MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS DODD
HI DOT ALL RIGHT NIELSEN ALLEN
SIX ONE FIVE ALLEN HI
ARCHULETA BAKER FORGES
BRADFORD BRADFORD AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE WESO AYE AYE WESO
AYE JONES JONES NO
KAMLAGER KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ NO PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I RUBIO WILK
AT SEVEN TO THE BILL'S ON CALL
NOW TO -- S. B. FILE ITEM
NUMBER EIGHT SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT BY SENATOR MCGUIRE
SECRETARY CALLED OUT WE HAVE A
MOTION CENTER HUESO
GROUP'S SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL FILE ITEM EIGHT SB
ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT MOTION IS
TO PASS APPROPRIATIONS DODD
DOT ALL RIGHT NIELSEN ALLEN
ALLEN HI ARCHULETA BAKER
FORGES BRADFORD
GLAZER HI GLAZER
ALRIGHT WESO WESO I'D
JONES JONES I KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO WILK
SIX VOTES -- BILLS ARE CALLED
SO MOVE ON TO --
S. B. TOOLS THE NEW
I DID TEN
FROM AROUND HERE SORRY
GUYS IT WILL MOVE ON TO
ITEM NUMBER TEN -- THAT
WOULD BE -- S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE BUT CENTER WILL
SOME OF THE THREE ANIMOTION
ROUNDUP CENTER BORDERS WHAT
TECHNICAL WORLD THIS IS FILE
ITEM TEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY
ONE MOTION IS TO PASS A
MINUTE TO APPROPRIATIONS
DOT FIVE DOT NINE NIELSEN
ALLEN ALLEN HI ARCHULETA
BAKER FOR JUST FIVE
BORDERS AYE BRADFORD BRADFORD
AYE GLAZER GLAZER AYE WESO
WEST THIS IS FILE ITEM
YEAH WELL THE FIRST NUMBER
NOBODY KNOWS
JONES JONES I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER I MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO HI RUBIO WILK
AS FOR THAT'S NICE
AS NINE VOTES -- WILL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL
SO THAT WE'RE GONNA MOVE
TO THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
SIXTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
WILL ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
JONES PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SECRETARY OF FILE I'M ELEVEN
SB THIRTY SEVEN MOTION IS
TO PASS TO ELECTIONS DODD
NIELSEN ALLEN
ALLEN I ARCHULETA
THE BILL NUMBERS RIGHT NOW
I DON'T THIRTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
WILK BAKER
VIRTUS ALL RIGHT FOR
JUST WAGES I JUST
FOR HIS AYE BRADFORD
GLAZER THIS IS MY CELL
JONES I JONOON
HI KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK BILL US FOR
VOTES WITH THAT BILL ON CALL
WE'RE MOVING NOW TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE S. B. THIRTEEN
FIFTY BY SENATOR CORTES C.
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
WE HAVE A MOTION ON THAT
ALSO CENTER GLAZER MOVES
I'M SURGERY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
FILE ITEM TWELVE SB THIRTEEN
FIFTY ONE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS DODD HI I'M
SORRY TO PRESIDENTE PREPARATIONS
DODD THAT I
NIELSEN THIS IS
NOT HARD ALLEN
ALLEN AYE ARCHULETA
AYE ARCHULETA AYE BAKER
BAKER I
BAKER I BORDERS PORGES
I BRADFORD FOR AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE HUESO HUESO AYE
JONES I JONES I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER HI MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I RUBIO
WELL THAT IS TWELVE
VOTES THE BILL'S ON CALL
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE --
TO SB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
THAT'S ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
BY SENATOR JOE ABOVE WE HAVE
A MOTION AT CENTER GLAZER
-- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL FILE I'M
THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
MOTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS DODD DOT HI
NIELSEN ALLEN ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA AYE ARCHULETA AYE
BAKER ALL RIGHT BAKER HI
GORGEOUS GORGEOUS I BRADFORD
-- BRADFORD AYE GLAZER
GLAZER AYE WESSEL WETZEL I
JONES ACT JONES I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER ALL RIGHT MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ I PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO AYE RUBIO WILK
THAT IS ELEVEN VOTES --
WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL AS
WELL THAT WERE MOVING TO --
FILE NUMBER FOURTEEN S. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT BY SENATOR
DOLLY YEAH MOTION SOME
OF THE CENTER JONES MOVES
US SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL THIS IS FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SB THIRTEEN FIFTY EIGHT MOTION
IS TO PASS A PREPARATION STYLE I
-- SKEWS ME THANK
YOU I'M HERE
YEAH THAT WOULD BE A NO
DODD NO NIELSEN SERVICE
THIS JUST THE WAY THE DAYS GONE
OKAY I'M REALLY APPRECIATIVE
YOU GUYS FINALLY SHOWED UP
MOVE ON OKAY MILSIM FALLON
ALLEN NOW ARCHULETA
ARCHULETA NO BAKER NO
RECORD NO GORGEOUS FOR
JUST AYE BRADFORD GLAZER
WESO WESO NOTES JONES
JONES I KAMLAGER
KAMLAGER NO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE PORTANTINO
GALANTINO NO RUBIO WILK
THREE TO SEVEN THAT'S THREE
SEVEN AGAINST -- THAT BILL
IS ON CALL WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
OUT TO ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN S. B.
FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO BY SENATOR
HERTZBERG WE HAVE A MOTION
OF NO WE HAVE A MOTION JUST
OPEN WE HAVE A MOTION WE'RE
JUST OPENING THE ROLE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL THERE'S A FILE I'M
SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN ARCHULETA
FIVE ARCHULETA HEIGHT BAKER
ALL RIGHT BAKER HI GORGEOUS
GLAZER MELENDEZ
RUBIO WILK
THAT'S NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
I SEVEN BEGINNING ON A
GOOD SENSE I CAN ONLY
YUP WHILE WE'RE SO WE'RE GONNA
START THE BEGINNING TO GET
THE MEMBERS SO THEY CAN --
BE LEAVING THIS MEETING CAN
WE FIND OUT FROM CENTER RUBIO
FIVE SIX MINUTES YEAH
OKAY SO WITH THAT --
LET'S MOVE TO THE TOP --
THEY'LL BE SB NINETY
EIGHTY CENTER WIENER
FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE
WE'LL START WITH THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SKEWS ME
I'M ON IT WAS
WHO IS ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
ARCHULETA ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ARCHULETA HEIGHT
BAKER FIVE BAKER HI
RUBIO WILK ON COLLEGE AND
THE FOURTEENTH WELFARE
THAT'S TWELVE ZERO -- THAT
WILL KEEP THAT ON CALL NEXT
ONE IS -- ITEM NUMBER FIVE
-- SB NINE EIGHTY CENTER
WIENER FILE ITEM FIVE SB NINE
EIGHTY ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HEIGHT BAKER
BAKER I'D GORGEOUS KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ RUBIO
NINE ZERO HOLD THAT OPEN
SB TEN THIRTY ITEM NUMBER SIX
SEVEN AMOUNT THIS IS
FILE ITEM SIX SB TEN THIRTY
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA HEIGHT
BAKER BAKER I'D FOR JUST
RUBIO WILK
THAT'S NINETY TWO THE IDEA TO
HOLD THAT OPENED -- THE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B. TEN
SIXTY NOT NOTICED CONSENT
SO MOVED OUT TO IT -- NUMBER
EIGHT ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT --
CENTER MCGUIRE I JUST FOLLOW
MY AGE SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
ABSENT MEMBERS NELSON ARCHULETA
BAKER ALL RIGHT BAKER
I VERGES BRADFORD
KAMLAGER MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ I RUBIO WELCOME
THAT'S EIGHTY ZERO TERM THREE
ZERO WILL HOLD THAT OPEN WILL
DESCEND -- TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
SKIP JUST TEN -- THAT'S
ITEM NUMBER TEN S. B. TWELVE
SEVENTY ONE WILK FILE I'M
TEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
ARCHULETA ARCHULETA I BAKER
ALL RIGHT BAKER HI WESO
RUBIO WILK
THAT'S ELEVEN TERM
ZERO HOLE THAT OPENED
MOVED OUT TO -- ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN THIS IS FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB THIRTY FIFTY SEVEN
ABSENT MEMBERS DODD ARCHULETA
BAKER BRADFORD
GLAZER WESO
KAMLAGER PORTANTINO
RUBIO WILK THAT'S FORTY
ZERO ON COST FOUR ZERO BELIEVE
THAT OPEN ITEM NUMBER TWELVE
S. B. THIRTEEN FIFTEEN CORTES
C. THIS IS FILE ITEM TWELVE SB
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN RUBIO WILK
FOUR ZERO TWELVE ZERO
WILL HOLD THAT OPEN
MOVED TO -- ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE OF CHAU BOTH
ABSENT MEMBERS OF FIVE ELEVEN
THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
ONE ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
RUBIO WILK THAT'S
ELEVEN
ZERO AS KIM
OKAY S. B. AS THIRTEEN
SIXTY EIGHT -- ITEM
NUMBER FOURTEEN DOLLARS
FOURTEEN A FILE ITEM FOURTEEN
SB THIRTEEN SIXTY EIGHT
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
BRADFORD GLAZER
RUBIO WILK
THAT'S THREE TWO SEVEN SEVEN
REPORTS OF A GIVEN ME ONE
MINUTE I MEAN DOUBLE CHECK
WHAT KIND OF ORDERS OKAY
YEAH WE'RE NOT THERE YET SO --
YOU WANNA BRING UP -- YEAH THE
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AGAIN NO NO
NO YOU'RE GOOD YEAH I WANTED
TO GO BACK TO THE SYSTEM OKAY
SO NOW WE'RE MOVING TO ITEM
NUMBER SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO YES -- HERTZBERG
YES FILE I'M SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN GORGEOUS GLAZER
MELENDEZ RUBIO WILK
THAT'S NINE TWO ZERO THREE
ZERO PUT THE BILL
ON KOHL'S WEALTH
I'VE NOT VOTED ON FIFTEEN
OKAY THEN -- HOW ABOUT
OF COURSE NUMBER THREE MAYBE
THAT COULD SET THAT
UP -- FOR
THE PROCESS IT SAID OKAY
NUMBER SEVEN
AND NUMBER NINE IN SAID
GOOD GRIEF
SO WE WILL RECESS UNTIL
SENATOR RUBIO GETS BACK IN THE
ROOM WE'RE GOING TO GIVE HER
EXACTLY SEVEN MINUTES
FOR THE FIRST TIME
CAN SOMEBODY ELSE A. B. BACKER
IT WILL NOT LIFT THE CALLS
SIR WITH THE CONSENT CALENDAR
SURVEY PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR
BUDGET COMMITTEE YEAH
-- NOW BACK IN SESSION AND
LIFTING THE CALL STERN WITH
CONSENT CALENDAR SURVEY PLEASE
OPEN THE WRONG THE CONSENT
CALENDAR THIS IS ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK
THAT'S THIRTEEN TWO ZERO
TWO THIRTEEN ZERO SIX CAN'T
CONSENT COUNTERS OUT WE WILL
NOW MOVE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE S. B. NINE EIGHT NINE
EIGHTY BY WIENER SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE FOLLOWING FIVE
SB NINE EIGHTY ABSENT MEMBERS
NIELSEN FORGES KAMLAGER
MELENDEZ RUBIO RUBIO I WILL
THAT'S TEN TO THEIR TRUMP
VOTE IS IS TEN KNOWS YOUR
THAT BILL IS ALEX -- NOW
MOVING CHIU FILE ITEM SIX S.
B. TEN THIRTY SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE OF ALL I'M
SIX SB TEN THIRTY ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN FORGERS
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK
THAT'S TEN TO TO CHARGE IS
THAT TEND TO TO THAT BILL
IS OUT REMOVED THE FILE ITEM
EIGHT SB ELEVEN NINETY EIGHT
SECTOR PLEASE OPEN THE ROLE
FILE I'M EIGHT SB ELEVEN NINETY
EIGHT ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN
ARCHULETA FOR JESS BRADFORD
KAMLAGER RUBIO RUBIO AYE
WILK THAT'S NINETY ZERO GERMAN
NINETY ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT
NUMBER TO FILE ITEM TEN S.
B. TWELVE SEVENTY ONE SO IF
I START SEARCHING FOR SIR
PLEASE OPEN THE RAW FILE ITEM
TEN SB TWELVE SEVENTY ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN WESO
RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK
THAT'S THE TWELVE TWO ZERO I
TWELVE KNOWS YOUR THAT BILL IS
OUT WITH A MOVE TO FILE ITEM
ELEVEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
SEVEN SECRETARY PLEASE OPEN THE
ROLE THAT IS FILE I'M ELEVEN SB
THIRTY SEVEN ABSENT MEMBERS DODD
NIELSEN ARCHULETA BAKER
BRADFORD GLAZER WESO KAMLAGER
PORTANTINO RUBIO WILK
THAT'S FORTY THEIR GERMAN
THE PROPOSAL YEAH
FOUR IS YOUR FORECLOSURES
ZERO THAT BILL FAILS
AND WE WILL GRANT
RECONSIDERATION ON THAT BILL
WHAT'S THE FUTURE BUT WHEN I
WOULD FILE ITEM TWELVE S. B.
THIRTEEN FIFTEEN SECTOR PLEASE
OPEN THE ROLE I FEEL I'M TWELVE
SB THIRTEEN FIFTEEN ABSENT
MEMBERS NIELSEN RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WILK THAT'S THIRTEEN
TWO ZERO THIRTEEN ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT NOW MOVES TO FILE
ITEM THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN
TWENTY ONE SECTOR PLEASE
UP IN THE WRONG FILE I'M
THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE
ABSENT MEMBERS NIELSEN RUBIO
RUBIO AYE WILK
THAT'S THIRTEEN TWO ZERO GERMAN
I THIRTEEN OH ZERO THAT BILL
AS ADULTS RENAULT'S PHYLUM
FOURTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN SIXTY
EIGHT SECTOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE FILE I'M FOURTEEN
SB THIRTY SIXTY EIGHT CHAIR
VOTING NO ABSENT MEMBERS
NELSON BRADFORD GLAZER
RUBIO WILK
THREE TO SEVEN SEVEN AS
YOU THREE KNOWS ARE SEVEN THAT
BILL FAILS AND RECONSIDERATION
RECONSIDERATION IS GRANTED I
NEVER TWELVE SIXTEEN SB FOURTEEN
TWENTY TWO SECTOR PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLE OF VIOLENCE HAS SEEN
SB FOURTEEN TWENTY TWO ABSENT
MEMBERS NELSON BORDERS GLAZER
MELENDEZ RUBIO RUBIO AYE WILK
THAT'S TEN TO THEIR TERM PRICE
TEN NO ZERO THAT BILLS ALPS
LEN THANK ALL INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATED PUBLIC TESTIMONY
TODAY IF YOU'RE NOT ABLE THAT'S
RIGHT TODAY PLEASE SUBMIT YOUR
COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE OR VISIT
OUR WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO
US AND WOULD CONCLUDE YOUR
TESTIMONY IN THE OFFICIAL
HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU WE
APPRECIATE YOUR PARTICIPATION
AND THANK YOU EVERYONE FOR
YOUR POSITION CORPORATION WE
CAN CONCLUDE THE AGENDA THE
SENATE COMMITTEE ON GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATION IS A CHART